Woof, woof, woof. And now
the fuck you doing man,
you're ruining the whole program.
The Joe Rogan experience is brought
to you by a bunch of different shit.
We've got a new sponsor, it's
called Ting. And what teaching is,
is a cellular company, a cell phone
company that they buy time on sprint.
They allow you to get great cell phones
on a great service with no contracts.
You don't have to,
uh,
pay any cancellation fees if you
only use a certain amount of minutes,
those minutes roll over to the next month.
So you only pay for what you use.
They have a whole tiered system.
It's a real simple, real easy.
And if you go to rogan.ting.com,
you could save 50 bucks off
of any of the new phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy s three.
That's the newest shit that they got.
That's pretty fucking bad ass.
It's a, uh, a huge ass phone. Uh,
I can't tell you that
much about the sprint,
the sprint service to be honest because a,
I just started using it but the phone
itself as slick as fuck the a galaxy s
three,
I had a used to have a droid and Brian
had the same thing that droid to shit.
It's way better now. Yeah, the droid
two's a hunk of shit. It's terrible.
But the Samsung Galaxy
s three is bad as fuck.
Go to rogan.ting.com and get yourself 50,
50 bucks off your dirty bitches.
Jealous of that. Actually
I get you on, you know,
you know how you had that
problem with Doug Benson?
Like you text him and he never got it.
Yeah,
I saw that happened two more times since
then and I saw it happened again last
night where like I sent text messages to
Brody and he never got it. Listen son,
your on and off.
Yeah I lost you. Are you know you're on
an FBI list? No, you are. We got freeway,
motherfucking Ricky Ross on the podcast.
You don't think you're all your cell phone
text messages. It can be intercepted.
Listen son, we've been ever since
Michael Roper was on this motherfucker,
we've run into lockdown.
That's why you shit's missing some
some FBI dude's wagon off to Europe.
You're dick pictures going to be worse
now it's gonna be worse down. Goddammit.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it,
we have new shit in hemp force.
It's a delicious new protein powder that
is made with Makkah and raw cocoa and
it's fucking sensational and it's easily
the best and most digestible protein.
You won't get nearly the kind of gas
that you get if you fuck around with that
way. Shit like muscle milk, it tastes good
but you'll fucking stick up the joint.
This is different.
We also have battle ropes and kettlebells.
The new wave of functional
fitness is a battle.
Ropes and kettlebells are a big part of
it and what they are is you're a using
exercise equipment that makes you
use your whole body in one motion.
Instead of doing things like curls
and like isolation exercises,
which don't necessarily apply to athletic
endeavors. Instead of doing that,
you're doing things like kettle bells,
which is like this bowling ball.
It's on a handle on your
swinging him around.
And what it does is it forces your
body to you to move as one unit.
And so you get strong and actually
move and shit around as opposed to just
getting like a good bench press.
You know what I'm saying? So, uh,
it's all interesting stuff. If you're
interested in it, go to.com, check it out.
If you use the code name Rogan, you
will get 10% off any an all supplements.
Also the for,
for the supplements,
especially the controversial ones
like Alpha brain free freeway, Ricky,
you will not test positive
suddenly gives you one of these.
You will not be in trouble.
Those are all uh,
this is all shit that your
body is just normal nutrients.
It's just high levels of
refined nutrients. Uh,
there's a hundred percent money back
guarantee and the first 30 pills or these
things if you, if you try him. And he
said, this is bullshit. And by the way,
I have friends that say it's bullshit.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I have people that I know very well.
They try it. They don't like it for me.
It's fucking elixir for me.
It's God's gift for Duncan Trussell's.
God's give Joey Diaz raves about it.
Um,
Lorenza Fertittas completely
addicted to this stuff,
but Brian doesn't even like it.
It doesn't even work on him.
Oh, I, I just, I don't see like it's for
a while I thought it was doing something,
but then I got off it and I was like,
wait, I feel the same and I don't know.
I think if you were on it, you shouldn't,
you be like more, I don't know.
For me it might be too retarded print.
Yeah. It might be just to pass that.
It might
be too retarded for Alpha brain, but
for me it's the shits, the new mood.
I'm all about the new bed. New Mood
is fantastic. Would new mood is,
it's a five HTP and l tryptofan a
supplement and five HTP helps your brain
produce serotonin and that actually
makes you feel happy or five HTP has long
been used as an antidepressant by a
lot of people. You take that five HTP,
you brain produces more serotonin,
which by the way, as you get older,
it just fucking slows down.
It's just you can either deal with it
and deal with this new level of feeling
that you have or you can supplement
and that's what I'm all about, man.
I'm all about taking the shit that makes
me feel the best. It's the most healthy.
That's why I'm down with Alpha
brain and dirty fucks. All right.
We are also brought to you by death
squad. Dot. TV. [inaudible] dot.
TV is the the website for
all of Brian's podcasts.
We've you see the website.
If you see death squad podcasts,
anything has desk over
that crazy cat on it.
That's all Brian's shit
and you can support that by
going to death squad d. Dot.
TV and there's two different,
a cat tee shirts. You go back.
Do you still buy the first one? No,
only one kit. That first one back sign,
it was a keeper. That's a whole thing.
It's like a collector's edition.
So once they sell out,
they're gone forever.
I need that cat in the second one
that can and the second one is evil.
That has to be on something
like we should, we should
make an actual sculpture.
Oh by the way, whoever sent
me that fucking Werewolf
having sex with the gorilla.
You're a bad motherfucker. I told a
story about a crazy dream that I had.
I told a story on the show, but I
should save this for after the podcast.
Go to desk squad.tv. There's two
different tee shirts that are Ville.
There's only one now. Alpha
brain, the new one, the new ones,
the better ones and new ones,
the better one anyway,
but you can also go to [inaudible] dot
com and you can donate to Brian through
amazon.com and what this does is like say
if you want to buy something on Amazon
anyway, if you go through Brian's website,
they'll give him a kickback. So G, G,
G G G G E d.com.
So there's all different ways that
you can help out the show and for me,
I just want you to be you. Oh, all right.
That's all I want out of your dirty fucks.
All right.
We got a hell of a show tomorrow night
at the Lobero Theater in Santa Barbara,
California,
Joe Diaz and Duncan Trussell.
But right now if we re Ricky
is in the fucking house,
we're going to get down to business,
hit the music,
Sun Joe Rogan experience Joe
Rogan podcast by night all day.
No
rarely in life does it become more
evident to me that we are on the wrong
fucking track as a culture.
Then when I pick up rolling stone and
rolling stone used to have hunters
Thompson writing stories about taking
acid in Vegas and they were spectacular.
I mean today they still have Matt Taibbi
who breaks down all the reality behind
the financial crisis,
but rolling stone has a guy on it who's
really fat and he's covered in tattoos
and he's got your name.
Yeah.
This is the craziest Shit I've ever
seen in my life as a human cause this at
this point is like, we are weird man.
We are a weird fucking species. Yeah.
There's nothing weird.
Or then like as if he,
if he hadn't called himself Rick Ross,
this shit would've never
happened for him as if, I mean,
what kind of faith does
that have in your town?
He could change his name right now.
He could change this right now,
his name right now to something
else and be just as huge. I mean,
how many times is puff daddy changes? Name
P, diddy none. And now he's just diddy,
you know,
think about that.
Well, you know, but his whole image
is based on the name. You know, he,
he's built his whole career
around this name and, uh, he,
he's afraid to change it.
That's a thing that some dudes do. Like
they'll call themselves Capone, you know,
they'll call themselves something
fucked up that's like, you know, I'm my,
I'm Tony Montana motherfucker.
They'll crawl,
call themselves somebody who actually
was a bad motherfucker. Yeah.
So when people don't know people
that aren't from my generation, um,
what they don't know is that during this
whole Iran contra thing that was going
on, when it became revealed
that Oliver North, that they,
they were selling illegal
guns and they there,
there was some drug dealing in the CIA
and the in the hood that was like wow.
Did Not admitted it was,
it was crazy times.
But my point is you became a prominent
fig on the news. There was a,
it was a big high profile case and before
you went to jail it was very evident
who you were.
I mean it was a big case.
Yeah, it was. It was a, an la times
once put me on as the Walmart.
A crack cocaine.
I think that's what he said though.
Hey Joe w freeways, friend. What is
your name again? Brother? His attorney.
Yeah. I had told him until I got to ride
with attorney now, hey, pull me over mark.
And from the old way you, you got the
perfect get though. He's young. Cool.
Know you lucked out.
Yeah.
Joe, we got to remember,
what year was it? 1996 right.
The guy says that he came up with
the name of [inaudible] 96. So in 96,
Rick's name is everywhere.
I'll tell him I'll globally
cspan congressional hearings.
And then the guy says,
I imagine it up in 96.
That's what he said. He, uh,
he has some cockamamie name
was a cockamamie description
for why he changed the
name. But the bottom line is you had
the name first and you were famous.
So it seems like he would have
to change it if he's going to,
it's not his real name. So he's gonna
change his name to something else.
Why would he change it into the name
of a dude who was already famous?
Who's like, I mean, if he's,
if he's pretending that it changed
it for some arbitrary reason,
like someone said something and I said,
I'm no, I'm Rick Ross, the boss, you know,
like, oh, you didn't know those records.
That's like calling yourself, you know,
I'm going to be Mitt Romney.
And he said,
I'll profess a philosopher
of gang and drug culture.
You know, he says that he knows all the
drug dealers and all the gang bangers in,
in, in the whole, you know, the
whole nature of the business.
Yeah. That's another sticky point. He
didn't know, but he didn't know about,
you know about me. That's crazy. Yeah.
Noriega Pablo Escobar.
Yeah. There was no one,
there was no Wikipedia in 96 unfortunately
though. Right. That's when he,
when did he start becoming famous for it?
The name Oh seven oh seven yeah.
Yeah.
See that's when we started to slide.
We started falling apart last year.
The Bush administration, but the
fuckers are losing hope. They'll like,
this doesn't even make sense. He's
like, fuck it, this can't last.
I'm just going to call
myself Rick Ross and boom,
cover of rolling stone kid.
That's weird. It's rolling stone.
Good story in there. You know, they can't,
they won't write a story about
you and they never wrote about me.
I used to write rolling stone when I was
in prison and tried to get them to do a
story about the drug war and what
was going on in the whole holding on.
But it's so crazy, you know?
It's like they don't like me,
but he can go on with my name because my
story and wrap on Monday night football
about selling drugs.
Did he wrap up Monday night
football? Really? What did he do?
He did try off it with a
Mariah Carey. Wow. And disease.
Talk about selling drugs in that song.
I mean that's all he talks about it.
I didn't hear him do the song,
but I mean everything that
he raps about these drugs.
Really. That's it. What's,
what people don't know is he used to
be a corrections officer like this.
The story gets crazier and crazier.
He's like a character
in a will Ferrell movie.
He's like some nutty dude
that gets exposed that has
been putting on this like,
it's not like he's putting on a hustle
in 1980 when you had to go to the library
to find out about people.
You tend to put a hustle a lot in a diff.
This is a different time, man.
You can't do that anymore. Yeah.
Where do you know our people
were so I don't know man. So,
so lost that it doesn't matter anymore.
You know,
you can come up and tell them
anything and they go forward.
And then once they discovered that they'd
been lied to, they still, you know,
kind of like just Mosey riding on a loan.
No, Rick, tell him how he
said he came up with the hike.
How you decided to be a correction
officer in rolling stone?
They called the big boss. No, no, no, no.
I heard that in the article itself that
you have in front of, he says that, uh,
he was eating peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches with his friend.
His friend got caught for selling dope
and the prince father just tells him to
be, as frank goes away, it goes away
and the father walks up to him. He says,
you need to get a job,
become a correction officer.
Yeah. Did you just explain this to
me? Like really recently told me this?
Uh, no, they was in the rolling stone.
Right. But didn't you explain
it to me recently too?
When was the last time I talked to you
before this came out? Yeah, ridiculous.
Cause I kinda remember that statement.
I mean you think about it and then you
think about it from the level of your son
just got, got arrested for, for
cocaine sales as far as 20 years.
First thing you're gonna say is to
his friend is go be as a prison guard.
Jesus Christ. Give him in jail. But
you know, they've done those studies.
They did a study, I think it
was at Stanford where they, uh,
did a prison guard study where they had
students pretend to be prisoners and
prison guards. And like almost immediately
the prison guards became abusive,
fake study kids,
just kids.
I worked as a security guard
at great woods. It was like a,
a performance arts place in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
It was like outside of Boston.
It was like,
while the big conscience would come there,
like Bon Jovi and shit. And, and uh,
I was a security guard there and I'm
not a big dude, you know. And so, uh,
I was like, someone's going to fuck
me up. This is ridiculous. You know,
being in a position of security, well,
I'm being, I'm just a security guard.
At a concert place,
but I swear to God,
within a couple of
months of working there,
you develop this us versus them mentality.
You deal with enough drunk and people,
enough craziness.
That dude's we're hitting dudes,
that guys who I'd never thought would
hit somebody. We're hitting people.
I wish that authority, that authority
over somebody and you feel that,
that you have
a whole system behind you and that you're
writing, you can't do wrong. You know,
matter of fact,
a guy that was in custody while he was a
guard had called me one day and told me
that this guy was one of the worst
cards that you could be. You know,
if you had an extra soup, he would take it
from you. Uh, extra stamp, you know. Oh,
you one stamp over.
Oh No.
Right into the sort of general, well, he
had an extra stamp. You know, like what?
I want to get a bunch of guys. You
know what? Whenever I get a chance,
I want to get a bunch of guys that was
in jail with him and just get their
stories and see
irony of it all.
Is it that you sit there and you watch
it like the bet awards and he hollered
out for all my guys locked up in,
Oh my God.
All the people that I used to tell the
shut the phone and then the guys in
prison are cried. I mean,
you got stopped that guy.
Why are you guys letting him do that?
Matter of fact,
I was with somebody a couple days ago
and they were saying that this guy that
he's been rapping about in his songs,
it's in prison. It's like, man,
the guy messed my appeal up.
You know,
I was on appeal and he got
it on the record and told
them everything that I did.
Oh, no way. Oh my God.
He told his story through rapping
what an asshole. Yeah. And,
and even Rick Ross knows what he did.
He fucked up his appeal.
That's ridiculous.
Uh, the, the,
he did a documentary on the guys in Miami
that was supposed to been drug dealers
and you know, in some of those guys are
like, man, he should have never did that.
He never got our permission.
He never asked us.
Wow. And now those guys are
exposed, exposed. Did you hear that?
Griselda Blanco, uh, got assassinated
the other day. Yeah, I heard that.
You know who she is, Huh? Of course
it's business business. He knows,
you know who all the key players Brazelle
the Blanco was the old lady in cocaine
cowboys that fucking, oh, you
weren't with me in Florida.
Billy Corbin, the guys at director
ever came and came to one of shows.
It's fucking cool guy.
Famous. She stayed alive. So
you know, after uh, you know,
going to war with Carlos Escobar and
she killed everybody,
that chick is responsible for the
deaths of who knows how many people,
but they eventually got her somewhere.
Well, you know, that's what
happens though when, when,
when you start that black market on,
on, on drugs or with anything, you know,
you give that,
that,
that power and the ability
to make so much money that,
that it just corrupts people and you know,
from all walks of life,
I don't think nobody's immune to it.
It does not work the same way with fame
like this. I mean it's, it's very similar.
Like what's happening to him.
Yeah. I mean that's very,
that's very corrupting as well,
right?
It would make you bullshit your way
through a story in order to keep your,
your money coming in.
We do a lot of research for this case and
I actually read an interesting article
by a sister. It was, it was an
interview with the system and he said,
she said he's lost in, in,
in this, in this image last.
Wow.
Yes. I mean, even when we,
uh, that's crazy. We went,
we took his deposition down in Miami was
the first time that me and him was face
to face in a room together.
I mean, he rode his eyes,
he gave me a finger,
it gave me the finger.
How long ago was this? Um,
and it's about four or five months
ago at least. Is Ridiculous.
So it's after you did this podcast?
Yeah. Yeah. It was after we did podcasts.
He gave you the finger. What does he
12 good fuck. Give someone the finger.
Have you ever done that? Like fuck
you man, Yo time. You do this in your,
in your car and you got to go
decreased shine. Who's like a
little five foot four white woman.
It's like who did he go
after? MTV. The host.
What happened? He said something
like about Rick Ross and then she,
he was claiming that he was going to
be filing against her and this lately,
but when the kingpins in the room.
Right.
Wow. Give you the finger
though, Huh? Yeah. That
alone is a victory when a grown man looks
at you and you don't say shit to him
and he has to give you the finger,
like come on. You silly bitch.
Yeah, but he's such a, I don't know,
you know his album flop this time,
did it, but he's on the cover of rolling
stone. Would, I don't think you can.
You can, you can have a flap the album
and still going to cover rollers. If, if,
uh, I'm going to call my agent. If you
buy it, if you buy, if you bought a cover,
I think all this stuff, you
buy it. I think you buy it now.
It's not about being good or uh,
you know, uh, being successful, you
know, it's about, can you pay for it now?
It's amazing that today in 2012,
this,
this image that he's projecting of his
underwear and then his pants like halfway
buckle, halfway down his underwear
was big fat belly hanging out.
Like what are we doing in
2012 were fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's funny.
It's funny Rick talking about robbed and
stolen cause it's been magazine did an
article on Rick that was,
I mean Rick Freeway,
Rick that was on the cover all week,
this weekend spend, did this, you know,
he was on the cover.
It's a great magazine.
There's some great expos stays in there.
And they did a piece on the rapper
called master of his own reality.
He talked about how he's creepy,
he's taking the criminal black man
image and just perpetuating it,
just using it to sell an image of himself
that isn't true because he came from a
good home.
Right?
So he's basically like a,
a character he's doing like
an Andrew dice clay character.
He's doing a pure character.
I think he's doing a copy of Rick and I
think that he's doing a copy based on,
well,
he's way faster than you.
Like he's not trying to just
trying to look like you at all,
but what does it mean you're not covered
with tattoos? He's covered with tattoos.
Well, you see, I look
like I'm on crack. So
you look like a healthy man.
God is probably gonna live to
be a hundred years old. It's,
it's people that are a really big and
fat that are fucked man. But your,
your heart is pushing extra hard for that
shit on how much cardio are you doing?
Yeah, well, you know, when you, when you,
when you got those people behind you,
you know what,
that money and they put some money in
your pocket and you feel like you're going
to live forever, you know, if money
or keep me alive and then I'm good.
Well that's certainly what happens.
So a lot of these guys, but it's also,
I think he's kind of stuck with what
got them to the dance and that's just
bullshit. It's just going to bullshit
bullshit until he slides into a wall.
You know what I mean? He's just going
to keep going while he's in motion.
He's just gonna keep bullshitting.
Why would he tell the truth?
He's not going to say,
listen, here's the deal man.
Well, you know, I wonder how it, when the
guy goes on radio stations and the host,
you know, they never, you know,
cause I heard him on a couple of radio
station and they never asked him, man,
why did you take this guy's name?
Well, why don't you, he's a big
guy. He kind of mad dog's people.
I've seen him mad dog,
some people that have tried to ask him
some things about you and he gets real
loud about and he's, yeah, he's like, it's
uncomfortable to be around like, dude,
that big. Who's pissed off? You know?
Yeah. I think we've been doing like a, um,
a viral campaign of truth.
And if you read the rolling stone article,
he spends a lot of time talking about
things that are uncomfortable for him.
Correctional officer
thinks things that he's
never talked about.
I totally didn't even
plan on reading this shit.
I just got it and I said
I have to bring it in.
Cause I knew there Rick was coming and
then he talks about playing football and
we believe it's because we brought up
the fact that when we called the school,
they didn't have a record of him
playing football and look at,
so he never played football
either. In check. We didn't
have, we just had this out.
I mean we reached out to athletic director
and they said that they don't have
him on the roster for the hall nineties
they don't have a William Roberts.
I mean I would love to see you the roster
and picture picture a lied about that
too. Why would that be surprising?
Have you ever heard of all of them
American football player without
one pitcher with a uniform on?
I don't know. I wouldn't be able to tell
you. How possible is that? I don't think,
I think it's impossible.
All the barriers can be an all American.
Like they take a lot of pictures of
those guys and that and but not have one
picture anyway. And how old is he supposed
to be? Is this supposed to be like 40?
How old is he? 35. He
graduated 26 so he's about 37.
That what Ted is 36 maybe.
He seems like he's fucking
crazy is what he seems like.
He seems like he's just some dude who
figured out a good hustle and he's just
riding it. Yeah. Yeah, he
is. But he's definitely,
definitely a crazy, I mean, you know,
they just spent one point $3 million
fight me in court to keep my name.
That's what they say.
They paid attorneys
now. Um, how did you, what did,
what did you do to defend yourself?
Did you defend yourself on your own?
Because you know a lot about law.
Yeah, but I had, I had
good attorneys with me. Uh,
you brought him as well from a Austin,
you're nessie. That's been helping us.
Um, and then myself, a
lot of research, you know,
really this thing is
going to come down to,
to whether or not he starts to
understand that we're not going on.
So they,
they essentially try to like spend so
much money that they sort of drowned you
in like,
hey, they worked. They worked. They
worked the hell out of my attorneys.
I'm talking about a couple,
wait like three months straight.
We was in depositions everyday.
Yeah. Wow. How is it again?
What a crazy world we live in.
How could that even take three months?
Cognitive.
How could they say they got
nine attorneys, but it's,
that's amazing, isn't it?
You really stop and think
about the absurdity of that,
that they would spend months on
that they would spend months on.
This is his name now. That's his name.
Okay. That's it. We're done here.
It seems like that would take three
seconds. It just shows you how mad we are.
We're like a mad culture.
I think that that with this guy that
once they sent him a bill for 200,000 he
would say, well, what's going
on here? We're doing. Nah,
they said it be for 500,000 and he
still doesn't say what's going on here.
Then they send him a bill for
600,000 he still doesn't it.
We up to one point $3 million in this
guy hadn't said, hey, you know what?
Let's sit down and talk about
settling this case. You know,
it seems like you could
giving you that money and then changes
name. Yeah, we got a foundation,
freeway literacy foundation. You
know, have him be part of that.
How much would he, would you take that
and then just drop everything? No, no, no.
All right.
How much would it cost to, to let him use
your name? You don't have a license fee.
There's no license fee. Yeah.
Okay, so essentially say,
let's say the dude loses in court,
but he wants to continue to call himself
Rick Ross and plus I guess he has to
compensate you for the UC lose in court.
He can forget it really.
If he wins in court, then like
where are you at right now?
How many times do you guys
been a before a judge?
Wait,
say that again.
How many times have you
guys been before a judge?
How many times have they done well? What
should I say? Have there been rulings?
It's been really like two rulings, two
rulings, three rulings would they say?
And what essentially happened was a Rick
first decided to go for it, freeway.
Rick decided to go to federal court
and when he went to federal court,
it's not the best place because California
has so much better protections for,
uh, I guess you could say personality
rights, name rights. So, you know,
federal course it go
take it to California.
We want to you that there's
a better place to hear it.
They came to California and first we
sued universal because the university is
the home of def jam.
Uh,
the judge that Rick was late in
filing against the universal,
but Warner brothers did
a, a new deal with, uh,
with the rapper William Roberts
Rosé last year. And as a result,
no, that, that's him as well. This
Rosa is his, is the same person.
Why does he have a bunch
of different names?
Uh,
maybe ah,
we have to, we filed a suit. He changed
it from Rick Ross to Rick Rosé. Okay.
Oh,
when did you start? Let's steal. The
thing is so much value has been putting,
let me start off by saying, ah, there's
a video of Leo Cohen, Liar Coin, uh,
the president of, of, of Warner
talking about a fast forward,
my name is liar at Leo [inaudible],
Leo l y r o talks about stuff.
They don't want to
develop artists anymore.
So essentially they try to
fast forward and what are,
what essentially happened we believe is
that that the labels looked at the fact
that this Rick Ross was untapped and they,
and they,
and they realize we can just put an
artist out and there's already like,
yeah. And so he said that the
name came out from him in 96,
but it really was like 2007 when
he started working. Yeah. Wow.
That's a crazy case,
man.
I don't know what it would be like walking
around where there's another man who
has my name.
Oh Man. It's, it's awful. People
call you and in the book you,
and they don't know if you
hear my, are you, you know,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's confusion. It's fucking weird.
But at the same time, it's, it's,
you know, I just want him to stop,
you know what I'm saying? I'm like,
why you got to take my name?
You know,
I built this name in and
he had had some crazy,
he was with funk master flex
and they said some crazy stuff.
Like I should be happy that he kept
me alive. And, and even with that,
if the guy would come out and
admit that he took the name,
would be a little more company, you know,
but when you sit here and lie to me,
you know, it just makes
it where I'm like, Oh man,
this guy here is totally full of,
so are you an appeal right now?
Like where, where do you stand?
We're actually in process of deposing
positive [inaudible] call it and Sean
Combs. We're moving forward with
trial against Warner brothers. Um,
the judge ruled in our favor as far as
Warner of others cannot take a statute of
limitations out to get out of the case.
And so we're moving forward
against Warner brothers
to trial. Wow. Whoa. That's crazy.
Now, what I will say is that there's two
fundamental differences with what Rick,
Rick Ross has done with them with freeway
Rick versus 50 cents of Jay z with
jazz old. And the first being that
this is his birth name. You know,
when you take somebody whose birth name,
especially somebody like Rick,
you essentially can create confusion when
you walk in the room cause they don't,
it's not a nickname,
they're not going to clear it up.
They're gonna be like it just how many
people walk in the room and say I'm
Stanley Roberts. Right.
It's just not their name.
So then the second thing
is that Rick's name.
Let's explain what you
meant by that though,
because a lot of people don't know what
you meant by Jay z and jazzy jazz. Oh,
was a famous neighborhood wrapper.
We're Jz lived and then JC
became Jay z and it's sort of,
he kind of like copy that.
Yeah, 50 sentence.
There was a bank robber,
but these are like neighborhood names and
like rights thing was in Time magazine.
You know, Rick Ross was in Time
magazine in 2001 the name, you know,
it was a congressional hearings date line.
This isn't a name that we needed to
be built up. So when Rick gets out,
he's getting approached by Nick
[inaudible], Arya Man, you'll Jeff Berg,
the top people in Hollywood.
He doesn't need the wrapper to build it.
Name Up.
It's just all so crazy because you,
you know that he says that he's
an expert on, on the culture.
So it's, it's, it's in snow.
Of course there's an article.
Look, there's an article
where he says an old l one,
I mean, I'm sorry. Oh six this
is the rapper show improve XXL.
He says it's rumored that
the guy started the crips.
Then you come out with the song with
Jay z and dre three kings where he says,
my cousin was a crip herder was a seat
thing. It's like, come on man. I mean,
how much are you going to do to copy of
the man's life? I mean, there are no,
I don't, I don't, I don't think there's
many crips and walking around Florida.
Wow. So strange. It's a strange,
strange thing to like lock onto that.
I wonder what his mindset is.
I wonder if he just feels like he's
got something successful then fuck it.
Why mess with what's good?
You know?
I'm just going to keep driving
until the wheels fall off.
Yeah, what do you were,
you know, but, but I mean,
any rational person would come and say,
you know what?
I've done good off of this person.
You know, they've helped me get here.
Let me go to the table in, in, in
square this up. You know, let me,
let me make right what I made wrong.
Because by right,
he should've came to me and said something
to me from the beginning had had I
not been in jail, he never would
have done this. Right. You know,
he never would've came and took my name
had I not been in jail and being under
the restraints that I was under.
And for folks who don't know, we talked
about us in the last time you were here,
but for folks who don't know,
he thought you were in jail for life,
but you because of reading a
different legal arguments in jail,
you realize that the three strikes rule
did not apply to your case because two
of the things were consecutive. Is that
correct? Yeah. So concurrent. Excuse me.
So he thought like a lot of people
did that you were in jail for life.
That was what?
That was what it was.
So we used to BIM in the labels.
Yeah.
What was all in the newspaper
and I had a life sentence.
So it's like if you tried to call
yourself giant Gardy, you know it's dead.
You know he could get away with it. I
mean, why would I want to be John God?
Yeah, exactly. Why don't you
proud to be who you are? You know,
can't you be yourself?
I mean you,
you're never going to make your
family's name. I mean, it's very silly.
I ever wanted in life was to take
my name and put my name in lights.
Not me. Go out and put Joe Rogan.
I mean, what does that do for me?
You know, how does, how does that
satisfy my craving in, in my knee?
And he's actually a second.
Well,
maybe he just thinks that's
the only way he could do it.
And when he thinks that there was
like, you know, what's the difference?
A lot of the rappers from
me accomplishing something,
I mean that you actually go out and
accomplish something. Not where, I mean,
you know, if you cheat and get it. Yeah.
Did you really accomplish it?
No, I agree with you. I think
anyone rational agrees with you,
but there's people that feel like
they can't make it without cheating.
They can't make it without stealing.
They can't make it without lying.
They can't do it. So they just do it. And
that's what they do. That's the normal,
goto mode is to be full of shit
and then just just exist that way.
That's a lot of people,
man. That's what it,
and that's,
that's one of the reasons I think that
our country is such in such bad shape
right now because we're in a mode of
fake it till you make it, you know? And,
and if you don't make it,
keep faking it.
I got a whole bit in my act I'm doing now,
we're trying,
you're trying to explain Kim
Kardashian to an alien. You know,
it's like you look at how ridiculous our
culture we're like really is now try to
try explaining sneaky to someone from
another planet to try explaining this Rick
Ross thing. You would, you would go crazy.
And then, and then the other part
of it is just to realize, you know,
when you say Rick Ross, you're
talking about the Iran Contra scandal.
It really a important part
of American history. Right?
And for him to come out and do that, he
dot lutes he confuses the story. So it,
it Kinda,
it hurts the product in a lot of ways.
It hurts history. Yes. Yeah. It's
confusing to people. You know, you're,
you're clouding it out. And then if
someone goes back and reads a Rick Ross,
like what is this? This, this with
us, this guy who it, I ran contra.
What the fuck is he with the wrapper?
Is that the wrapper? And then it's just,
what did they have the same name
like this? Some dudes are born,
the name is Ray Charles. Like, good
fucking luck with that. That's retarded.
You bet you got to change your fucking
name is already a ray Charles man.
You know what I mean?
Well that's one thing if your mom named
you that. Yeah, you name yourself,
you've got to come up with a nickname.
You know it's ridiculous.
You know Dave yourself today.
Isn't that? That's ridiculous.
It's so stupid. Can you imagine if
you're a young basketball player?
I tried to call yourself Michael Jordan.
Not Michael Jordan didn't,
what the fuck you talking about man?
There's already a Michael
Jordan like people are crazy.
This is just more evidence that
we're completely losing our minds.
No.
But the thing you got to realize this
is what about if it's on purpose because
you want, you want to walk in
that room and get that interest.
Well,
I think he probably started it out
when he didn't have as much of a,
an understanding of how
quick information transfers,
but it seems to have worked enough that
he's on the cover of rolling stone with
all these fucking diamonds. So there had
to be some benefit to it for him. Oh,
absolutely.
He's covered in diamonds.
Absolutely. Where he knew that, that
basically in the streets, you know,
because I basically hid from,
from people, you know, people didn't
see me, they didn't get to know me,
so nobody really know what I look like.
So when he came out,
they just had heard the name.
The name was ingrained in people's mind
and people just gravitate to the name,
you know, I had, um, and
the almost in an APP,
chuck away without even really remembering
the case, it was almost like, do you,
did you, you know, you know, a fucking
may org, uh, what's his name? No Noriega.
Do you know what Noriega actually did?
Most people don't
named Noriega. It sticks.
Yeah. No tonight. Cause it's
been out there so many times.
You heard it. He's actually counting
on people to not know. Oh absolutely.
Absolutely.
And that's how he's benefiting right now
because people still don't know because
people are starting to,
matter of fact,
we did a photo shoot a couple of weeks
ago from a guy who was just reminding you
from the Netherlands, from Netherlands,
and he was saying when he came over there,
they booed him. Oh Shit.
Yeah. They actually booed
him on the stage cause right.
No, it's up. When was this?
How long ago was this?
Uh,
maybe about a month ago.
Oh Shit. But you know what? I know
I podcast has legs and Netherlands,
which you know, they're not going to put
that on the news. Yeah, of course. Well,
we'll make the cover of
rolling stones. This, uh, this,
what you're doing now is coming
on podcasts and putting shit on.
I've seen a lot of your other interviews
that you've got online and you know
you're, you're, you are,
is spelling it out calmly,
rationally, not emotionally. You know,
you're just spelling it out and it's,
and you're saying the same
fucking thing every time.
And then you see when people
try to corner him on it,
it's like this weird awkward mad dog
moment. We're just kind of gets loud that,
well, you know, we're not about all
that, you know, moving on something else.
We are about money. Oh, rude. Jude
said. He asked him about, uh, uh,
the price of, of, of an ounce and shit
though. This is, this is
like, oh seven oh eight.
Jude. Jude say he asks you about the
price of an ounce of cocaine. He was,
what did he say? I find
real healthy. Yeah.
He said the guy didn't
know the price and roots.
He didn't really know cause roots,
I don't know about no gains.
So it just fuck with him and see what's
up. He thought that he really knew.
He thought he was really me
at that time, you know, so he expects
them to give you an answer. You know,
somebody come in and said
they think their butcher,
you going to ask him about me,
you know, somebody asked me, man, what
was the obstacle can you going for,
I could just, you know, just right off
the top of the head because I've lived it.
You know I was there but you know somebody
who hasn't done it then then you know
it's total rough to him.
So,
so he got caught quick that was there
that he can get caught more often.
But you know right now,
I mean media is media anymore.
I mean it's not a mouse.
We pulled in the truth.
That's why it's so good that you know,
people like you are doing the
podcasts and the Internet, you know,
because right now with, with the
mainstream media man, they all bought,
oh it's done isn't it?
CNN go socket. Yeah,
they're all done.
I mean,
if you listened to the radio,
you're going to hear 10 songs
over and over again, you know,
the same 10 songs over and over.
The shocking thing though is the news.
The news really is shocking.
There's a lot of shit that just doesn't
get described. And the way it's,
the way it's explained is like,
it's very off.
Like try getting the real scoop on
Wiki leaks from Washington News.
You don't know what the fuck
they don't give us the
BBC, BBC, his license
ABC is great. You know what? It's
also great. I'll just zero. I'll just,
zero is pretty honest news.
You know, there's, there's
people in other countries,
it's still look at the news
and they look at journalism,
like they have an obligation to
show the uncomfortable truth.
And that's why I think that Brandon's
Seidenberg, the guy who spent magazine,
yeah.
Shout out to him because he did a really
good job of getting this piece out.
And what's funny, we put it in, he puts
in in Spin magazine, makes the cover.
We didn't know it was gonna be on
the cover and then the next morning,
Costa Rica Times runs it of all paid
to places that Costa Rican time.
Wow.
Yeah.
In other countries they can still tell
the news as long as it's not about the
drug dealers that are local.
Okay.
We tell the news about other
shit. You know, it's, it's,
it's a sad statement to where,
how far we've fallen as a country that
you just watched propaganda on TV.
What do you want to be able to be done?
You know, if the people are dumb and in,
in, in, in, you know, just following
what they say, follow, then you know,
it's easy for them to control what's,
what's going on. You know? Well
it's this Mitt Romney guys terrifying
is Mitt Romney guy is not even a real
human being.
It's the strangest thing.
Yeah.
Like straight out of the fifties
those old das father knows best,
the Da,
what do you kids doing today?
You're not getting into any
treble or, yeah. He doesn't
seem like a real human.
He sat down with some guy who was a gay
Vietnam veteran and the guy asked him
about gay rights and he probably didn't
think that dude was a veteran. And uh,
and uh,
you know,
it just said he wasn't into like gay
people being married and then the guy just
trashed them after he
left. It was great. It was,
but it was awkward watching Mitt
Romney communicate with them.
He's just so awkward,
Dude.
It's like when you hear him see
him talking to somebody, he's like,
do you interact with anybody?
Like who are you interacting with?
Like he's interact, he's like in
some fucking silver room, you know,
counting diamonds.
And he occasionally has one of his
minions will come in and ask questions,
but these are the guys that he
was really, really, really rich,
like hundred million dollar rich.
He's a fucking stupid rich guy.
So he's awkward talking
to like regular folks.
Like when was the last time he's been
like a regular dude? Like, you know,
out there going to subway and a buying
a sandwich and shit and he's like,
he's an odd duck.
And, you know, that's what we
need. We need some regular people,
people who are out here dealing with
real life situations that no, you know,
the gas, it costs money. You know,
it's like a lot of times these people
don't understand that, that uh,
we have real problems out
here on the streets. You know,
that there's people that have
to ride the bus. You know
how funny thing also was the watch the
difference between the two conventions?
Like when he watched the Republican
convention, it was awkward.
You heard about what they did to
the reporter? The CNN reporter? No,
they threw peanuts at her and called
her an animal. What black CNN recording.
What is it on camera? Uh, I don't know
if it's on camera, but it was everywhere.
It was everywhere in the news.
Holy Shit.
I vaguely remember skimming
through something like that.
But I had to run out the door and I never
want you say CNN reporter peanuts. So,
so when you say it's awkward,
you just look at the democratic
platform and the Democratic of edge.
It was like all accepted.
Yeah. That's wow.
CNN camera woman had nuts
thrown her her at the GOP. Whoa.
That's insane.
Absolutely insane.
Tonio has like a, an encyclopedia,
you know, if something happens,
he knows about it.
Oh that's, that's pretty intense. He
gives me the only saving grace of the,
the Liberal Party is that
they're much more for a quality,
whether it's sexual equality,
racial equality, equality.
The problem is when they start doing the
same shit with corporations and start
accepting giant amounts of money
and then they, they're both,
they're both basically beholden
to the same people at the top.
But you benefit socially when
Democrats are in, you know,
you know, that's how the
whole system right now,
everybody's been being paid for,
you know,
by big corporations.
It's staggering. It really is staggering
when you stop and think about it, that,
you know,
you look at the amount of money that's
donated to campaigns and you look at some
of the things that people have said that
they would do before they got in the
office. Then you find out what they
really got to do. It's like they really,
it's not, they don't really have
a say. You know, I mean Obama,
if you could get Obama and he could
do whatever the fuck you wanted to and
everybody just had to listen. Do you
think you would run things this way?
I say no fucking way.
I say there's an idealistic young
college student inside that guy's head.
He's too close to that. He's too young.
Too Young, too smart to articulate.
You got to know that at one point in time
there was a dude was kicking back who
was hoping for a better world.
I hear he his finger on the trigger
and he can't get nothing done.
That's when you know when you get his
finger wasn't on the trigger. Yeah,
he can't, he can't put it on the trigger.
He can't really, he doesn't see it,
I don't think.
I don't think they have a say.
I think it's just like
being a sitcom character.
I think you get in there and then they
tell you what the fuck are you gonna do
and you, you, it's not one
person pulling the shots.
I think that's why they killed JFK.
He tried to get crazy. You know,
JFK just decided to say,
listen, I'm going to fix things.
I'm going to run things the right way.
I'm going to get rid of this federal rule,
a bank. I'm going to do that.
And they were like, what?
You're out here getting the fucking car
stupid. We're going to get rid of you.
Yeah,
you're not doing it. This is a
money grab. This is not, you know,
it's not really all about
running the country.
It's about making a fuck load of money
and run the country while you make a fuck
load of money. But you know what? What
they got to understand that if eventually,
if the money doesn't trickle
down to the normal people,
if the normal people keep living in
the conditions that they're living in,
that that revolution is gonna come.
You know what I mean?
They said it happened in all these other
countries. You know, which they help.
Well,
that's why I know passing these new law,
that's what all these national defense
authorization act and the ability to
impound people without having
to give them due legal process.
All that stuff that they're doing right
now in passing through law is to just
prepare for civil unrest prepared to do
things legally because somebody wrote it
on paper,
something that's absolutely a moral,
so that's what they're preparing to do.
They're preparing to do everything the
same way by rain is doing it the same way
Saudi Arabia is doing it. I mean it's, we,
we have to look at all these
places like Egypt and Libya.
You have to look at that and go,
worst case scenario,
someone could go fucking crazy here too.
I got this,
I got this crazy crazy and
email and it had a pdf and it,
and it was from bank and it was about,
it was,
it was a pdf that only was sent to
the elite clients and it was basically
telling them how to manage their money
in the midst of chaos. Chaos is coming.
It's a specific name for it.
I have to look at my email,
but it was just talking about like the
percentage chances of this happening or
that happening. Walked off. Fuck.
That's his soul.
It's so hard to wrap your head around
the fact that that might be our future.
Like that. Every culture,
you know, since the look,
go to the go to the Roman empire and go
look at all those broken down buildings,
how come they never kept up
those buildings? How come
people didn't keep living?
I'm, how can we, cause the whole thing
fell apart. There was nothing left.
I mean,
the whole thing just shattered into the
rocks and it had to rebuild itself with
time. And that's, that keeps happening
over and over again to people.
We get to this point where we get super
greedy and we have a lot of money and a
lot of resources and the people at the
top just hoard over that shit and then
boom,
it hits the rocks.
Yeah. You know, like one,
100 million is gone be less.
If you lose 5,000 I mean $5 million
or 200 million, you know, you know,
you're not living any better.
You know, you can't, it's only so
many cars you can drive in so many houses.
You're going to event,
they say after $40 million,
your life never changes.
Well I think what happens though is
that people get crazy and then they,
it becomes like a mad game to them
and they can never have enough chips.
Just want to keep just,
I,
I know people that are rich so that's
still get fucking jazzed up about making
money. They still get fired up
about it. I don't, I don't know.
I don't understand it.
You know like you do when you want to.
Like if you were Bill Gates,
wouldn't you want to just chill and
there's no way you're going to spend all
that money. But for him he's got
this empire thing in his head.
He gets off on controlling,
you know,
all these different operating
systems and you know,
having all these computers all in having
this giant market share, you know,
conquering and moving forward and
creating new technology and creating new
Xboxes and shit like that dude still
pushing it. It's amazing. You know the,
those guys get addicted. He could,
he could retire a hundred people.
He's got billions of dollars,
man.
That's assuming the money is going
to be worth anything, you know,
I mean tried to get ahold of some
rolling money. What's that? Shit works.
Yeah. If it's gold, it's worth
a lot. And that fucked up
then when they didn't have anything man,
I mean there was no cars, there's no TV.
People still agreed on gold. Like you can
get me some of that shiny yellow shit.
Well back then it was probably the,
you know, it was probably, yeah,
it was probably poppy seeds and shit
and poppy plants and the leaves. Yeah,
they'd been to in those leads so
years. Oh the coca leaves. Yeah. Well,
which is a really healthy way to do it.
They say for high altitude people
in Peru, they a, or you know,
you say pedal,
if you want to do a process check
that you know how to say it right.
When you're in Pardot white guys that
talk like with authentic Spanish accents
are annoying as fuck.
But anyway,
you get get ahold of those cocoa leaves
and you chew it and apparently it's
better than coffee and justice.
Healthy and it actually gives you like
alkaloids and it gives you some minerals
and shed and a fido nutrients
from eating the plants.
The leaves like chewing it up so
it really is like not bad for you.
It's just when you turn it into
cocaine that's when shit gets freaky.
The person who found that out.
Yeah.
Who's that asshole started
this whole fucking problem.
You could have just been a cocoa
leaf dealer. Everybody but fine
if it was legal. See people don't
understand. If cocoa leaves, we're legal.
We really have no problem.
As long as nobody processed that
and turn that shit into cocaine,
it's a great thing to have.
If you can make tea out of it,
that gives you a lot of energy.
You can chew the leaves
or even if they didn't had
dispensary's back then. Yeah,
cocoa leaves dispensary's if they had a
weed dispensary would you've gone into
that? Oh absolutely. Really?
That's it, right? Yeah.
That's everybody's going to be fine.
That way
when you get robbed by non,
we'd spoken people
when they know that you
got money and we'd there.
The real problem is getting and put
you in jail. And that's the bad part.
So I was going to say,
we're going to take your money,
your weed and put you in jail.
Well that's
what a lot of people don't realize is
that happens a lot when they are rob you,
they take your money, they, the cops come,
they steal all the plants and they take
all your money and they don't ever have
to give it back. It's like, it's
never going to get that shit back.
He'd go through court.
Good luck getting your fucking weed back.
You Ain't getting your money
back. Stop it. You know,
it doesn't matter if it's legal,
it's not federally illegal.
So they just challenge it on a federal
level and you've got to drop it.
That's crazy. But you know, when the
people can't, can't decide for themselves.
I mean, wow. I mean if the people
vote to make something legal,
I mean I think it should be legal.
It's the same thing like this
fake Rick Ross Guy. It's,
there's a transparency of the information.
It's so obvious it's,
it doesn't make sense.
So it's still around and it's just one
more piece of evidence that shows how
crazy we are.
The marijuana one,
it's not like there's nothing
that can get you fucked up.
It's not like marijuana is the only thing
that we've ever had ever that gets you
fucked up. You know? And then
people would be like, man,
maybe we shouldn't really be messing
with our normal state of consciousness
because everything seems to be going
smooth as long as people are sober.
But there's a lot of shit they
can get you fucked up every way.
You go to every cvs you go into,
you could
die. Yeah. And then you come back to it,
as you said about the transparency of
Rick Ross mean you gotta look at this.
Yeah. You could have a school, it's
called it school, that they'll say,
we don't want the drug dealer coming
in and talking about literacy.
The former drug dealer, let me say
that right. Was that then it does.
No gives talk. No, that's it.
They don't want to I Rick coming
here talking about literacy. Right.
But then turn around and authorized
Rick Ross to come in and do hustling.
You just about drugs. Isn't that,
I mean I just, it makes no sense.
Well you didn't even learn how to read
until you went to jail, right? Yeah.
I was 28 years old when I learned how
to read. Wow, that's incredible, man.
Your story's so,
it's the,
what I've always said is that the
number one problem that we have in this
country is that people are not caring
how young people that aren't there is it
growing up and you got to look at young
people as like the number one piece of
potential.
Like if there's anything
that has potential to human
being and you have human
beings that grow up with no future and
no fucking chance and no hope and no
nothing and no education and no love,
we just making a shitty person like that.
That's, it's almost like you've got
to find out where we're bleeding.
If we're an organism.
Yes,
a shitty society because that one person
is going to going to bleed on somebody
else.
It's going to create a ripple effect.
It's like we've got to find out where
we're wounded. Where are we wounded?
We'll find that spot. Whatever that
spot is. Culturally, where are we?
Where is the most amount of crime where
it's the most amount of despair was the
least amount of love.
Dan needs to be patched up and
until they patched that shit up,
we're never going to figure this out.
You're always going to have craziness.
That makes no sense.
Like this fake Rick Ross' character or
like marijuana being illegal or like Mitt
Romney were insane. Snookie we're insane.
We're, we're an insane culture witness.
We've never been more insane as a culture.
I mean,
I think shit was probably
insane back in the Elvis days.
Shit was probably insane
when the Osmond were huge.
Okay, but this is, we've
never been this insane. Well,
now's your technology kind of does that.
I mean,
when you think about the exposure
element of it all, you know,
I was thinking about my grandmother.
My grandmother grew up in a set in the
town where she saw the same people every
day. We see all new people every day
when you can be who you want to be.
It's great if your towns full
awesome people. You know,
I've always said that the thing that we
should do is organize place where you
could go and everybody's awesome.
Like everybody decide to buy a house
and it's one spot. But the bar cheers.
Yeah, you don't want to,
you want a neighborhood,
you want to hold neighborhood for all of
your friends. But that's hard to do, man.
We have cars so we fuck it up. We don't
have like a neighborhood tribe anymore.
Like it used to be that you would live
around only the people that you knew.
Like, okay Mike, I'm going
to make my house right here.
You want to make your house right
there. We're good. If you hear a bear,
wake me up. You know? But now it's like,
why would I have a house near you but
I can just drive to your house. I mean,
Brian's house is fucking half an hour
away from it. I don't drive to his house.
You know, Joey's house is a 10 minutes
this way and Eddie's houses over here.
I don't drive to anybody's house.
You know,
like it's not like they're all in your
neighborhood and you go knock on their
door. You know, it's not like you're
all together in a little tribe.
So we're all dysfunctional because we
have these giant groups that you would
think, oh, these mother
fuckers all know each other.
This is a giant group of 20
million people living in La.
But now nobody knows anybody.
You don't know anybody anywhere near you.
You're constantly surrounded by strangers.
It's the weirdest thing ever.
And people were really
shitty. Now, I mean,
have you tried to pull over like
changing lanes on the freeway,
on the street and the guy next
to you speeds up and yeah,
he's going just fast enough to keep
you from getting over. And I'm like,
Damn Buddy. I mean, what was it
going to give you 10 seconds.
You can get there 10 seconds later.
Well that's the whole thing that comes
out of that. Not knowing everybody. Yeah.
Because essentially you don't have to
be responsible. Today I might meet you,
never see you again,
so I can be whoever I want to be to you
and then tomorrow I'm gonna see all new
people. That is true. That is true
and that's not good necessarily,
but the other hand is you get exposure
to a lot of different kinds of people.
She get a pretty,
a pretty broad sense of what's possible
when you think about like meeting human
beings,
you know,
we're a regular person might not get
such a crazy view of people that if they
all watching Kim Kardashians.
That's true.
If you just go to the same spot every
day for lunch, same Hollywood club.
Wait for famous people to walk in.
Who's Dad? Is that her sneaky. Sneaky.
Oh, that fact never crossed the
temporary. What's her son's name? Guido.
Is that what his name is? That his
name is that she just made that up.
Please.
Please let hairy baby.
I heard that to Harry Baby. No keys,
baby probably is going to turn it out.
It's just all snatch hair that fell off
during the birth and just stuck to his
head. You can't clean them
off. You just scrub all day.
Those fucking hairs are
glued into this head.
Lorenzo dried snuffy snatched juice.
It's better than gorilla glue.
Could you imagine,
man,
you're going to wake up and be fucking
four years old and you go wait a minute.
Mile. What do you do? What do you do
that check from that show? Oh Shit, Matt,
would you be in like five
year old watching Jersey
shore and that's your mom and
she gets punched in the face
by some dude at the bar.
Did you ever see her get punched in
the face? She got punched in the face,
man by a teacher.
Wow.
You know you're in an annoying can't
when a teacher is at a bar and he punches
you in the face, imagine be 30th so
when it's a your son, and by the way,
the guy who punched her,
it was like a teacher and an MMA fighter
and she was like saying something to
her and she just punched her right
in the face on TV. Like what?
First of all, what a piece of
shit that dude is like this.
If he didn't know a camera was there,
like he didn't know he was just hammered.
He had no idea they rushed him to jail.
Oh fuck yeah,
of course they did the quickness saw
dude. He cracked her too. Yeah. Yeah.
What did you try and we saw it
with a deadly weapon. Well, no,
because he didn't hit her with anything.
So I think it's just a soil arch.
MMA fighter. Yeah. But I don't
think Pam, I don't think I'm,
it matters man. People think
that it matters. Like, Oh man,
your hands with deadly weapons. No, but
you know, it doesn't matter man. Shoes.
Shoes are weapons. You got
a problem. You pulling it up
right here. Watch this shit.
Yeah. This is a watch this shit.
Oh.
Oh,
that's a cracked her one more time.
it's kind of a slap punch
punch man. It just wasn't good.
He was an MMA fighter,
but I bet he got his ass kicked a lot.
Well he went that he probably got
paid a lot of money to punch her.
Do you think they paid him to punch her?
I do know that show is completely fucking
like 99% fail. Even think of that.
I don't know about a punch though.
That's pretty fucking real. Right?
That seems like you really did hit
her. It did seem like he did. Yeah.
But you know, they can fake them.
Those motherfuckers got us again.
I had a fake punch,
a dude once and I accidentally hit him.
It was like a fake bar
fight in a, in a, um,
a sitcom and I accidentally hit the
dude. Yeah, you could. You could.
But I think like sometimes like
in, um, uh, those fight scenes,
like dudes get really fucked up.
I didn't, Sylvester Stallone,
he broke his fucking neck and like
60 years old filming a fight scene.
Apparently his neck is fused
with a plate. Yeah. Yeah.
I tell them about the beer that you heard.
Do you remember about Oh,
by William Roberts beard.
This bank,
his beard got online where they show
you how to fix his beard out. Oh.
How'd they make it thicker or
something where you know his beard.
He can't grow facial hair.
Come on carpet in fucking out of here now.
You just made that shit up for real.
It's not, they showed it to me. No, they
showed it to me online. A girl was like,
Hey,
uh, go right here and you can see how
they fix his beard. His beard is not real.
It's a piece of carpet. She made
a good point. She was like, Rick,
how long you've been going your beer? And
I say, oh, since I was 18 she said, well,
you got holes in your beer. I said, yeah,
always trying to get those filled in.
And he never fell in. She said, well
look at here is you don't have anywhere.
He said,
isn't it perfect?
Brian grows a beard.
You don't have holes in your beard.
You Shit grows pretty thick.
Uh, yeah. It's, yeah,
I can grow a pretty
thick beer too, man. I,
they got it online where you
can see the guy fix it up.
You can see like them glue it down and
shit and the whole thing. That's crazy.
The whole,
that doesn't mean
any sense. Do you think the task
was a real, imagine that shit's real
tattoos or fake? Like you catch him
in the shower. It's all running.
Can you take the Rick Ross offers
knuckles? That's bizarre. Huh? Huh?
It's got your name on his knuckle
and then he says he doesn't know you.
I don't know you
so strange.
Oh Wow. It gives you the
finger. Wow. You know,
we're going around now and you know,
basically just, just trying to, uh,
trying to do what we just talked about,
you know,
educating the kids that are on becoming
critical thinkers and let them know that,
that eventually we're going to have to
take the power back into our own hands or,
you know,
be led to slaughter.
We have a nonprofit now to free
freeway literacy.org. You know,
pretty wide literacy foundation.
Been talking to a couple of
celebrities about getting involved,
being on the board. And
it's more, it's about,
of course literacy in regard to reading,
but also leadership literacy
and financial literacy.
Cause now coming back to our point
in this and this whole life podcasts,
a lot of people can read and write,
but the question is,
what are you reading and writing DNC was
all last night and if he was watching
sneaky over the DNC and you
went to college, you got
problems. You know, I've read,
uh, I watched a very convincing
a video today by this guy,
I think his name is Stefan Molyneux.
He's a
lots of her from Canada, but he, uh,
had a very convincing argument on
why you shouldn't vote. He was like,
it's fucking bullshit.
It's like you're,
you're contributing to a
game by pretending it's
real. And essentially you're,
you are,
you're,
you're giving into this fucking shell
game and rooting on this fake leader.
And then it's not real.
Like this whole system has been bought
and he had a very convincing argument.
And also watching the DNC might be like
watching a pro wrestling event before
summer slam, you know,
might get you all fired up,
but really what the fuck is going on
behind the scenes and not it saying,
it ain't Bill Clinton telling you
how much better you are. You know,
Bill Clinton's just trying to win.
So he get his dick sucked again.
Get up there and say
something dope as fuck.
So it comes off and he's in a
cocktail party and next thing,
some chickens suck in this deck.
I was just reading the article to Rick
about bill and Dan just to, you know,
exposing that whole Fannie
Mae, Freddie Mac. I mean, he,
he said everybody's gonna
get a house. Well, yeah, some
people can't have, yeah. Some
people can't afford a
fucking house. And, uh,
also the strange death of Vince
Foster, you know, he was involved.
People forget he was involved with some
giant real estate scandal and a Clinton
and his wife. And then there was a
dude named Vince foster who was a,
I forget what he did. I forget his whole
deal, but I remember that in Arkansas.
Yeah, he was a, he was a big part
of this whole case, I believe,
and he turned up dead and
with 80 went to jail. Yeah,
with the gun still in his hand.
It's like they see his wife went to jail
for contempt of court. She wouldn't,
she wouldn't testify. That's probably a
good move on her part. Well, you know,
the good thing about me is they don't
allow me to register to vote anyway,
so I don't have a choice.
Yeah. At this point, you're
probably better off that way.
It sounds ridiculous,
but this is Stefan Molyneux guy had
a very interesting take on it. It's,
it's reluctant. It's like, well,
it's all those people like, Woo.
If you want to fucking change things,
you need to get out and vote and
you got to go. Really? I'm not sure.
Well, Joe, I think they, I
think they also, you got to
look at what type of vote,
maybe on the national level that
applies both on a local level.
You can vote with your feet, vote, vote.
We're going down to the old council.
People go vote with your wallet too.
But people don't even go
down to the council member
meetings and talk about that
pothole that's in front of
their house. It's true. You know
you're right. That's true. Local,
local politics are real. That's legit.
That's why Arnold Schwarzenegger
couldn't get shit done
because of Joe Rowe. Hard on got in
there and saw what a tangled mess.
This whole thing was. They, I think they
thought they'd be able to clean it up.
It's a mess. But I think like
mayors, governors, you know,
things along those lines,
that's real. You know, they can really
change things and effect things.
You get to have a good mayor.
Shitty marriage. I mean,
look what happened in New York City.
Like how in New York City was cleaned up.
I mean, so it's a strange thing. You know,
a strange thing how much something can
change with the right guidance and the
right leadership, but federal
level man, it's like if,
if it really got anything done,
it floating really could change things.
They had figured out a way to fuck it up.
They figured out a way to make it illegal.
Yeah.
One of the things I was even telling Rick
was I was looking at some of the local
elections in like 20,000 people.
We could mobilize to 8,000 people and
picking you want to pick for local?
Yeah.
Elections.
Especially if you, uh, if you guys do a
podcast to a freeway, Ricky podcast. Yeah.
You think we should fuck.
Yeah,
you're going to be residential or
grade on it can't be like to me,
I barely know the vice president
of freeway studios studios.
I think you could do it man,
for sure.
You would be able to really
mobilize a lot of people that way.
People like hearing your talk,
man,
you got great stores and your life is
fascinating and you think about what you
know, what a podcast is, is if you can
be entertaining and interesting you,
you then all sudden you got a group of
people that are tuned in new and they get
used to you and they say there's
sort of like become your friend.
And that's sort of what happens on
this show. And so you know this show,
people know that if I'm
telling them something,
it's because it's true or it's because I
believe it's true. I'm not bullshitting.
And when people get to know you,
they'll know the same thing. And,
and then from there you can, any speech
you're ever going to do somewhere,
any thing you want to get passed through,
anything that you want to let people
know about that they don't know about,
you have a voice and you have a voice
that, I mean, it will start off with,
you know, x amount of people and then
it'll double and then it'll triple.
And as long as you keep doing it, next
thing we know. Yeah. Next thing you know,
you got your own fucking radio show,
you've got your own freeway,
Ricky radio show.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
Yeah,
cause I know I still get people to come
up to me for my last show that we did
and said, hey man, I saw you on Joe Rogan.
I was at the dub show like two weeks
ago and in downtown La at the convention
center and men at least five or
10 people came up to him and you,
that was great job. You did know with Joe
Rogan saw. That was almost a year ago.
That's awesome. The dub show man there
that that market's taken a hit man.
The big wheel market, you know Margaret
taking a hit, all the luxurious markets,
but the big wheel market,
even people who have like Nice cars,
they don't buy the big wheels anymore.
No, no, no. You're doing good though.
The magazine you mean? Yeah.
They had about 50,000 people
on it. The car show. Yeah.
I just bought the new magazine.
They have cool cars in it, man.
It's fascinating shit like
what people do their cars.
People do in their cars up there.
Like Mr Cartoon,
the Tattoo artist and a couple other
dudes. So I don't know who they are,
but they had some pretty bad ass cars.
But the big wheel market,
nobody wants those wagon wheels anymore.
You don't want spinners on you.
How large the spinners last.
It's like the legit lifespan for spinners.
But I see him once in awhile.
Yeah. Dana white used to have him,
well, you know, president of UFC changed
spinners, changing people's appetite,
you know, today is big wheels
and little wheels, you know,
and the next week his big wheels again.
And then it's the meaning of males,
you know,
just,
just a way to keep pulling that money up
out of our pockets so that we don't, uh,
yeah.
Take that money and that power and put
it to where it could really benefit to
people.
Well, it's also just a distraction.
People love Shiny Shit, man.
If you can give my shiny ass wheel whoa.
I saw a dude who had like a Chevy Caprice,
caprice classic,
and there were the most ridiculous
wheels I've ever seen in my life.
It was like a 10 speed bike wheel.
It was just a phrase. It's like,
what the fuck are you doing with your car?
This isn't,
this isn't even a car anymore. Yeah. I
see him all the time. It's so strange.
Like I don't even know how he got
into the car. It was so high up there.
It was like an acrobatic event just to
his front seat to deal with this crazy
stupid wheels. It's weird,
man. People are strange. Yeah.
Well that's the state
of America right now.
Have you ever understood the
monster trucks? No. No. Yeah,
I watched them before. I've only been
in one. I was in Quentin rampage.
Jackson is a giant monster truck.
He had a monster truck with a picture
of his face. We're from Atlanta.
I know, but get away from like,
well Quinton's from Memphis. Yeah,
you gotta be from the middle
of the country. The cool
thing is the height of it,
you know, looking out over, it's like
you're in a city bus, like looking up.
It's weird. Like you're looking
above the traffic. It's cross train.
You see your car.
He has some German car that's really
popular with the German army and it's,
it's like a Hummer but taller. Like I'll
try to find a picture of the electric.
Uh, no, no gas guzzling horrible
car. Yeah. No one's coming.
Miles a gallon. There's real
problems with electric cars, man.
You know the people want to go electric,
but you realize that electric relies on
lithium ion batteries and they get that
shit from war zones. You know, anywhere
where there's lithium, people are dying.
You know the lithium and the
Congo, there is lithium. There's,
there's pockets of lithium
that were recently found in
Afghanistan. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Lithium is a, it's a
scarce, scarce element.
And when they find it,
man, you know, they,
they try to lock down
that area and control it.
So it's like you're not really going
to get a conflict free car that runs on
electricity.
Cause that shit runs on a lot of lithium.
So they've got to pull that out of
a mountain somewhere in Afghanistan.
That sounds all your avatar. This,
you do it. You're right time.
They get this motherfucker. Oh
Wow. Look at that stupid car.
You silly bitch. He's just ready. He's
ready for the end. The end is coming.
It looks like he's been pumping up. It
doesn't mean it's getting back in shape.
That's a Mercedes. And is that a monkey
in the back? They get the Sig on.
That's a dog dog. So that'd be like a
cigar. I'm going through the maid's house.
I think that I had a crazy dream
about him. Yeah. He don't give a fuck.
I had a crazy dream about him.
Um, uh, after his whole case,
and I talked about it on the podcast, it
was real weird band. He was, uh, in my,
my family's yard.
They had a yard that like,
was like right up next to like a lake. It
was like a lake or an ocean. But anyway,
there's swimming and Arnold was
running around swimming with,
it's like balls and cock hanging out.
And he was really,
really confidential. Strolling. Oh, wrong.
No big deal. My Cock is hanging out.
It was just so casual. But his dick
hanging out. I remember thinking,
you got to keep women away from that guy.
I tough fuck and this is
my crazy dream of course,
but it was just such a strange dream.
See some old in shape guy
with his dick hanging out,
just swimming around near people.
It was a strange,
people feel like they, they, they
more privileged than others. You know,
we can do whatever we want to do
because we got on the guns. Yeah.
Do you think that's his attitude?
It feels privileged. Absolutely.
So Hollywood sty of a lot of guns.
I'm going to talk to my aide
and everybody else that gets in my way.
Yeah.
Just shoot loads into or didn't
give a fuck expendables too.
Did you? No, I didn't say it to Joe. I
saw the first one was good. It was okay.
Yeah.
The first one was fun if you want,
it's like a good episode of Dukes
of hazard, you know what I mean?
But at the same characters like today,
still good.
You know what that's
about is with something that
you said earlier, you know,
you said that you know we should invest
in kids, but Americans, the old country,
it's like what it to be where
like 58 then you watch TV,
everything that's honest for them.
What is the numbers of people?
I don't think that's right.
Just to be average age of people.
America used to be a,
in the seventies it was like a young
country because the baby boomers are
getting old.
So now America is like an old country.
So when you sit and watch television,
that's why every, it's all for old.
So what does the average person,
how old do you have? 50 something
before
maybe maybe late 40 so I might be wrong,
but it's definitely not enough.
30 all right, Brian, take
gas before I hit enter.
Uh,
35 35 I think I'm with you.
I'm saying in late thirties.
That's what I say. Cause I know there's
a lot of people fucking these tests,
let's say.
MMM
hmm.
Median Age was 28 in 2012
so not quite.
I saw that Joe, I saw that.
Did you see that advertisement?
Somebody found a old commercial,
uh,
of you in it on Oh,
it was like in the middle of
some fields. Yeah. Of a field.
You're talking about 22 years old.
It was so weird.
Yeah, it was terrible
and so awful to, yeah,
it seems like that's what it is
at 28 yeah.
It seems like it's 28 what?
S in the middle. Not Young,
but not old either.
Well,
this one though says United States
median age is 36.9 it says the average is
36.9 because for men it's 35 years.
For Women it's 38 years.
So that would say that you are about
right. Yeah, we're about right.
35 36 yeah.
Either way.
That's probably older than
people were back in the 70s we,
we're a young country cause the,
all those babies,
that's why everybody went
crazy and was doing drugs.
So I'm listening to Jimi Hendrix
and fucking all that shit. You know,
happy times. Happy
Times. Right. But growth,
but what a crazy little burst of energy
that time was and then to have it all
pulled back. You know, it's like for all,
for one 10 year period from between
1950 and 1960 the world changed in a Co
Raisie way.
I mean it really changed
like a motherfucker and then
10 years later everything
became illegal and then they
put the lockdown and everything.
1970 they passed all those drug war.
Yeah.
That's when they said no more acid
and no more. Anything else. Stop it.
People were taking all kinds of crazy
shit that was legal at the time.
Yeah.
Somebody said they used to even put coke
in cocaine when Coca Cola and put coke
in Coca Cola. Yeah. Have you ever
had the real coke? I had that.
The Mexican coke,
which Mexican coke is different.
It's cane sugar instead as delicious.
Whenever sugar we use
coke is better. Yeah, I fucked
up. But they don't have,
I haven't had seen Mexican diet coke,
but they have cane sugar
instead corn syrup, which is
way better for you. Oh yeah.
Isn't that ridiculous?
Shit they put in sodas is the worst.
I haven't drank a soda and about 25
years. Really? Totally cut him out.
Smart. They're so delicious
though. The check a coke.
Yeah. I mean when you, uh, when
you have like a, a nice sandwich,
you know that you want a coke to
go with that shed tastes good.
Burger Burger and coke sucked for it.
You're like, I eat these Kale shakes man.
And uh, it's not my favorite thing
to eat. They don't taste good.
They're this big fucking blended shake
that I make where I stuffed Kale in it
and celery and ginger
and garlic and pineapple.
But when I drink them, I feel way
better. But I'm like, why can't I,
why can't something like that draw me
to it? Because every time I go to it,
it's like work.
It was like,
I can't believe I'm drinking this
fucking disgusting Shit. And I'm like,
all right,
it's going to be delicious.
I'll start talking myself into it and
then I'll pour like a lot of coconut oil
on and a lot of lot of pineapple in
it so it tastes a little bit better,
but it really doesn't taste that good.
If I had to choose between that and a
soda, I would want that. Soda, Sodas,
just sodas like pain free.
Ah, Kimmy, Kimmy, some,
but then you won't be looking
at as young as you do. No,
I won't be feeling as good as healthy
as you are right now and, and you know,
and health. This is so important,
you know, and not a time.
I tried to tell him, tell this
motherfucker, tell him to stop smoking.
I keep telling him I want him to,
he's, he's getting older and he smokes.
He doesn't take care of his
body. And I'm like, dude,
I don't want to be over your bed
where you got some cancer type shit.
The rapper he had.
You heard about that another route.
What does that work with the rapper?
He had to eat better,
but he had seizures and then
he had to change his diet.
That's in the rolling stone. Article
Two oh, oh Rick Ross had seizures.
So you're the changes that like fake
Rick Ross. So he had to change his diet.
That's why he has a song called
pine dice. Pineapples. Yeah,
he's had two heart attacks.
Right.
And he's made two songs about
it as heart attacks is just
a lion and slinging Dick
till he hits the wall.
When you had a bunch of heart
attacks and you that fat
your shirt,
I'm bloody,
you know he probably wasn't getting laid
until after he started rapping. Yeah,
it was probably his balls
don't know what is going on.
Why so many loads.
How the fuck did this guy gets so
successful with his dick was like for 35
years, nothing. All of a sudden, every
day it's like we need more loans,
more loans.
Imagine if you will like in the load
factory in his body and then all of a
sudden production went up by like 5000%
in his thirties the fuck is going on,
man.
What do we do with all this berm?
It's just him eating sandwiches,
getting his dick sucked,
counting your money,
trying to figure out how much he can I can
give you and still live like this is
part of thinking about it right now.
In his mind.
He said none and
I go give him a die.
Yeah.
Well if he has to change his name to Rosa,
at least he's like set this, the sate,
the stage for that, you know? Right.
I mean that kind of has, right.
You said he's sort of using another
name now. He's usually Rick Ross.
He still using that constantly covered
a rolling stone. Yeah. Maybe that.
Maybe they did that too.
Was, I mean maybe there was,
it was like this is what we're
marketing so before we totally lose,
let's keep that going on. Maybe they
just figured that's the best way.
Do you think that got to know that
they're gonna lose? Right? I hope so.
I bet the lawyers listening to this
shit right now. Nah, I bet they are.
If they're good. Right. Wouldn't
you be listening to this?
You're on top of everything I watch.
I watched it.
You know? I mean, just for me, you
know, businessman and I said, okay,
well we just spent a hundred grand.
We know we're going to have to
spend at least another million. Hey,
you want to go and sit down and talk to
this guy and try to work this thing out?
But no, his orange was like, oh
no, keep sending those checks and,
and pay 1.3 million out of selling.
They say 200,000 records,
but
I think it's probably more like
25,000 what he actually sells.
No, this heats up my
opening week. They sold,
they say so think they'd lie
about that Shit. They buy,
they buy the records themselves. Do we
don't know if they bought him in his case,
but we,
but they do buy records.
So that's really what
companies do that all of them,
they do that just to jack up
the sales to make it look,
make it look like the guys is hot when,
when he may be not as
interesting, make him go, go.
Really? How many do you have
to sell before you go gold?
500,000 and platinum's a million.
Yeah. Yeah, I didn't know that.
They just could just go buy them like
that. Well, it makes sense though.
It's kind of
unethical or illegal to do that, but
they all practice that. That method.
Really? Yeah. Well it kind of makes
sense. You know, look, if you,
if you wanted to think about it that
way or you get like brag about the guy
selling so much, people
will, we'll try shit.
The here is real popular and then you
started to get advertisement bt or pick
you up and they started to play your
videos and MTV and oh he sold 500,000 so
now you're hot. It's a weird
business. That music businessman,
that seems like a strange,
strange place to maneuver. Joe,
can I ask you a question? Sure. Please.
If my name was William Robertson,
I rapped about being a correctional
officer. What? You buy my CD?
Yeah, if you were good.
Yeah, man. Yeah man do.
You could have any fucking job
and I don't care what you do.
You could be a comedian, you could be
a rapper or you could be an author.
You get if you're good,
it's not, it's not like the,
the title of what the guy
does. It's like, who is he?
You know,
like there's a lot of people that are
working in Baskin Robbins scooping ice
cream,
but they're interesting mother.
So if you were a sat down and talked
to them for a long period of time,
they might be able to actually write a
book that's pretty fucking bad ass he
would want to read. He might be
able to rap about ice. It'd be like,
I'd never thought a motherfucker could
wrap up ice cream and I would think it
was fun.
It's all depends on the individual and
the context of what they're saying.
So that guy for sure could have pulled
off talking about being a corrections
officer.
He just had to be a bad motherfucker.
I just think rap is so
anti-authoritarian. It's true. You know?
And especially like how he's trying
to rap. Yeah. Correction Officer.
Yeah, that's true. That's true. Lack
of drug dealers tackle people down.
People Squat.
We're going to take him down.
You'd have to be unbelievably [inaudible]
been over and spread his cheeks.
He would have to be m and m
times a million. Yeah, I checked,
I checked up on his nut sack.
He would have to be, you know,
a million times better than Jay z. But if
he would, it's like it's not impossible.
It's just he would have to be
so good to overcome that hate.
It would be almost impossible.
Okay. You know what I'm saying?
I really think that anything is possible.
What can you do it?
Can I do it and that bump?
Probably not.
But is it possible that someone could be
so good at rapping that they could pull
off being a bad mother fucker, even though
they used to be a corrections officer?
Probably going to happen one day.
Maybe.
It's possible you'd have to be
sold just it'll be in your dream.
Don't Arnold Schwarzenegger. Yeah, it
would be William Roberts. It just pass by.
If not was a corrections
officer. [inaudible] was,
his lyrics are so God damn good.
You got to just respect it.
You just can't deny it. I never
heard anybody says it. Nah Sucks.
Cause his lyrics are so good. That one.
We played the whole song backwards,
like the, the events like you, he reads
them backwards. Like, come on man,
who the fuck can do that?
Who else can do that?
Even if he was a corrections
officer, you'd have to go, God damn,
that was pretty fucking bad ass.
You know what I mean?
So he didn't have to be that good,
but he's not, he's not that good.
He's not that good at all.
Which is really interesting that
everyday I'm hustling that God,
that's like a good, it's got a like a
catchy beat to it. That was pretty good.
Yeah. You know that came
from dark alliance because
that's what you said. Yeah.
That's something, one of the
things that you said, right?
Yup, Yup, Yup.
Huh. That's so weird. You're
going to close you here for day.
I'm hustling everyday. I'm hustling
and you must be in a club going,
what the fuck is going on in this life?
You know what was funny to me,
a about a month and a half ago,
I was in Charlotte, North
Carolina. And so this kid,
he did a rap against the rapper.
You know,
only support the real oh
wow. To the fake. Whoa.
And so the wrapper and they all sitting
in VIP and they played around on the
radio.
Oh No. Got Guy. He calls me
like, you know what I'm saying?
Right next to that dude right now.
And they just played this song on the
radio because he did he know that it was
him. That was the place that he know. Oh,
that's hilarious. Just talked to the kid.
This all came
on and you know,
it's telling my Heidi was
terrible place to be, man. To
be full of shit to terrible.
No, I mean that way you can get
the stomach. I mean, he's been,
he's been there for a while.
You just don't get there overnight.
Yeah, that's true. Yeah.
He's a slob. That's amazing.
That's a fascinating story.
It's just a you,
you're admirable in how you
are depicting it in a very,
you're not vindictive, you're
not angry. You're like,
I barely feel like your heart goes
up a beat when when you bring it up,
you just bring it up
very factually with like,
okay, I just want what's mine. Yeah.
But I mean it's, you're not, you're
not freaking out about it. Yeah.
No I'm not.
But a,
I'm not going to rest until
I get it straight in the eye.
He don't understand that type
of person that I am. You know,
when I had my life sentence in prison,
one of the things that I committed
myself to was getting out of prison.
And now one of the things
that I'm committed to right
now is to get my name back,
you know, to stop him from using my name
and I want my name back with interest,
you know,
gimme my interest with my name.
How much did you take to shut up?
I don't need to say shut up.
That's disrespectful.
How much would you take to drop it?
I don't know. I really, I really
couldn't say right now. Uh,
we'd have to sit down and crunch
the numbers cause you know,
I got attorneys that I got to pay to.
These guys been helping me out of
the kindness of their heart and, and,
and it's put a strain on me,
you to fight in this case because
I don't make much money. You know,
I get a few dollars in the work
that I'm doing right now. You know,
when I go out to a high school and speak,
they don't pay me for that.
I take books.
We need a Rick Ross podcast and a
Rick Ross t shirt. Well, let's do it.
As soon as you start selling them on the
podcast, we do that. Just that alone, man.
I'm telling you. I did.
Yeah. I, everywhere I go,
I see these machine tee shirts from
Bert Kreischer for Christ as a comedian
friend of ours,
he told a story on the podcast about
getting drunk and Russia and he was saying
the wrong. He was saying, I'm the,
I'm a machine. I'm the machine.
That's what he's telling
all these Russian people.
He didn't know what the fuck
you're saying. And he's hammered.
So it became a hilarious story that
now he sold these shirts that say the
machine on the bottom,
these fucking shirts are everywhere.
I seen them in the country smart too.
Cause I got to see him in Dayton.
He will do the whole
machine story like an,
it's like a new version of it where he's
tightened it up and made like, you know,
like just even put it to the next level.
And then when he's done he's like,
and I have machines shirts out front.
And then like everybody after hearing
that amazing stories like hello, bye bye.
You can't go wrong.
Gets rid of thousands of those. Fuck
yes. I see those desk squad shirts.
I see death squad shirts
at every one of our shows.
I see desk squad shirts at UFC. I see,
I see them constantly. Did you see
it last night on TV? It was
on uh, America's got talent.
One of the bands was wearing
a desk. Squad shirts. Yeah,
that's a pull that
out. Pull it up. See that's
what I'm talking about. We
need a Rick Ross t shirt.
We need a Rick Ross podcasts or Rick
Ross t shit. Just that alone man.
Just that again,
you need to get that started yesterday
for real cause you can talk man.
You're an interesting dude and I see
what you're doing on your uh oh that's
hilarious.
And hit their cat on NBC.
That is hilarious. And a, I saw what
you're doing on your website as well.
Your um, your, your,
your website has a lot of news and a lot
of news about shit that's going on in a,
in the world as well. Like you, you, you,
you put like little blurbs of things
that are happening on your website,
the people that you're
involved with clients. Right.
I want to be informative.
You know,
I want to let the people know because
I believe that that just like you,
you're doing,
uh,
it's so much bullshit out here that I
want to cut through the bullshit and, and,
and help the people get something
that can help them, you know, with,
I think the most important,
important,
the most important thing is for us to
get our country back on track. Yeah.
I love the way America used to be,
you know,
and right now I'm not happy
with the way it's going.
I'm not happy with fake it
till you make it, you know, uh,
just be around the people
with money or with the,
right now these people would rather hang
out with somebody that has money and to
go out and try to make some money for
themselves. So we got to change that.
You know, we've got, we've got to
change it to, to where you are a star.
Everybody's a star and everybody should
be treated like one. I don't think that,
uh,
you know,
this guy's a bigger person than you
because he has money in the bank or uh,
I'm smarter than you because
I don't have any money.
I think we all created equal.
We all have talents and that we just
have to explore everybody and give
everybody an equal opportunity.
That's a beautiful idea.
On paper.
The problem with the way this world is
screwed up is that it seems like the debt
is so considerable. It's almost like the
whole thing doesn't make sense anymore.
I don't understand finances that much,
but when you start talking
to the trillions of dollars
of debt and we talk about
like what the interest rate is and you
talk about like how much people will be
paying off and where social
security coming from and what,
when you started like
looking at those numbers,
it's almost like this just seems broken.
It is broken, but the only way it's going
to get fixed as we fix it if we don't,
no it works because it ha,
that's what I'm worried about.
I'm worried about does it have to fail
before it can be reinvented in a more
productive manner? Is it, is that like
the destiny, this culture can fail,
failed. It seems like it had been. If it
hasn't, if they don't consider it failed.
Right now we have over 2.3 million
people in prison right now.
We are the biggest, uh,
incarcerator is in the world.
If that's not a sign that you're failing,
then what is,
well, what's insane is how many of them
are in there because they didn't sell a
sanction drug. They lock this person and
it's not like it's not drugs for sale.
It's not like he can't go to cvs and get
fucked up anytime you want special if
you have a prescription,
but even if you don't have a prescription,
you could walk into cvs and just
drink til you're dead, you know,
no problem whatsoever.
But if someone's selling some unsanctioned
substances and there's a demand in a
supply and they're these
dudes selling Oxycontin,
sees a fucking guys live in
behind velvet gates, you know,
no one's coming after them and knowing
that they're just collecting the just
watching zero is just,
it just sit in front of the computer,
logged onto their account, watching
clean, clean, clean. It's like a,
like a lottery bell going off
and now here they are giving kids
prescriptions because the kid is, is,
is moving around fast. They got
some drug that they're giving him.
Sure. Ritalin, Ritalin is famous. They
give kids that are hyperactive, but they,
they're doing Prozac on young
kids. You know, this is the I,
there's my next door neighbor. They were
terrible. Parents are about parents.
Their fucking kids were always screaming
at each other and they didn't know how
to handle it.
And they would scream at each other and
there was a lot of nonsense going on.
The kids just were fucking,
hey, why are they went haywire?
And then they started drawing them. It
was crazy, man. It's crazy to watch.
It was like all of a sudden the kids
would just be like looking at Ya.
I would leave the house and they
would be bouncing off the wall.
You try to pull out the driveway,
excuse me,
that fucker in the street jumping off
the car, you know? But that was normal.
At least that was like what crazy kids do.
Kids do.
Then you pull your car out
there and he sees Zombie kids,
same kids to stand there.
Chef man, we, we used to call it an
NGL when it, when they would, uh,
certain guys that they would put on drugs
when we in jail and they would just be
standing there going back and forth
with their feet and we would call it the
thorazine shuffle. Oh.
So it's awful when they,
when they do that to young kids, you
know, cause that stuff really mess you up.
It's scary.
How many parents just want to
calm the little fuckers down? No,
they just can't take it
anymore if you don't,
if you never had a kid you don't
know. You don't know how, how,
how's frayed people get? They just get
to the point where they can't take it.
They can't tag it, drag him up,
drive him, preparing to go to prison.
That's what they do.
Sad.
Put him on thorazine and,
and when he's old enough to say he don't
want it anymore and then we'll just put
him in prison.
Yeah it is.
It is pretty fucking pathetic.
How many dudes when you were in jail
were, uh, were on different medications?
Oh Man. Ally's be huge. And
will you, can you get them?
Like if you say I'm depressed,
well yeah, you can just go into the
doctor and give them a story. You,
you hear noises or
really? Yeah. And then what kind of
Shit they gave you? Thorazine or,
or the one that you just said
a the or PROZAC. PROZAC. Um,
and when they take those, then all of
a sudden they just zone out [inaudible]
yeah, you would see him standing in, in a,
in a spot and they just go back and forth
raising one foot up after another one.
Whoa.
Ngo is called the thorazine shuffle.
But all those drugs kind of give
them the same type of effect.
Do any guys in jail ever get
pain medication? Oh yeah.
You can get pain medication
if you hurt your back. Really?
All kind of shit. What can you get it?
Hopefully they don't give you a, you
in jail.
And I don't think so.
Imagine if you take Viagra
that a dude snuck in his ass
just seems like a bad path. When I was
in jail and everyone was talking about
coaches who a time. Yeah. And I
don't know, I didn't ever try it.
Homemade alcohol. Is that what it
is? Yeah. Yes. Homemade alcohol.
What do you have to have wrong
with you to get pain pills?
Like what kind of pain pills they
give out. Oh, you can go in there,
hurt your back, you know. And so if
you pulled a muscle, pull the muscle,
get hurt on the football field hockey,
I put some oxycontin's,
I don't know if they give you oxy cottons,
not they do have medicine that they give
you and you have to go up and you go to
the doctor and they put it
in a cup and then white.
Then you got to throw it in your mouth,
drink some water,
and then open your mouth up so the doctor
can look inside and make sure that you
took the pill. Those pills
are like really, really,
uh,
subscript prescription medicine.
But then they would give you like
a hybrid profile and you know,
you can just bring those back to yourself.
It doesn't get you high. It's fine.
Right. But the, those are
the ones that the gay,
how long they give them to you for.
I mean,
this guys didn't get them
for as long as they India,
but you have to keep going up to
the window every day. You know,
some guys go three times
a day to get the medicine.
But what they'll do is some guy,
instead of taking it,
they'll put it on your tongue and
get back in the unit and sell it. Uh,
there must be a skill. You develop how
to Tuck it and hide it. And you know,
if you do it for a couple of years,
you perfected.
Is there anything that you would,
that people would be surprised
that you could get in jail?
You can get cell phones,
you can get anything in there that
you can on the street if you guys,
if you got money. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
Pretty much anything. Cocaine, heroin,
uh,
Oxycontin, crystal meth. Everything
is inside the jail house.
I would have been like
playstation and you know,
I just like something that make it easier.
Just wasting my time in jails.
The hot steak deals now give
you a playstation. Yeah.
That's not bad. You didn't have
it in like, yeah, but if you lose,
you have to suck all the old games to
get Paul Madden too to go to share.
So, um, so could you get a
steak? He was asking, can you
get like a fat steak? Yeah,
you can get a steak easy.
Really?
They have stakes for the guard.
So the responds to about like I heard
about Rick Ross and so I get on the phone,
he said it like, like it just happened
instantaneously. Like he jumped the yeah,
you can get, you can get pretty much
anything in there, you know, they got,
they got guys in the kitchen that will
cook your meal just the way you want it
every day. Really. But you
got to have money. Right.
How much does it take to get
a steak? Uh, probably like $5.
Yeah, that's nice. But it's hard
to get money in jail or can you,
you got to bring in money.
You got money on the fence.
If your people got money on the
trucks, they can donate it to you. No,
they just send it to your
books or say for instance,
the guy in the kitchen and cooks,
he knows you.
So he gives you credit and then you
could just tell your people, hey,
this is the guy's name.
This is his booking number.
Sent him $300 that'll cover you for
the whole month or two months or three
months.
So whenever you come in the kitchen,
he just automatically bring
your tray contracts, contracts.
Does anybody have it?
Like that scene in Goodfellas,
whether in their cooking they got a
razor blade and the chocolate shop it up,
the garlic and the fries.
You have it set up like they have,
they have like a cell that's pretty bad
ass to him. No, no, no. Wait a minute.
They do fix the sales up, but
not with outside stuff. You know,
they might have outside
radio. What? Outside speakers?
Uh, stuff like that.
There may be a blanket,
you know that that come from the outside,
which you can't have a bed that
comes from the outside. I fellows,
they had like a whole apartment in jail.
They were walking around with slacks
on and shit. No, not, not, no.
You can't have that in the
feds. They gonna make sure
everybody has the same bed.
Uh, some guys have special
mattresses, especial mattresses.
You can get a special match up
the last day before you left,
all your guys come in and
sleep in yourself. Oh yeah.
Yeah,
they stayed my last night that I left,
I left at like four in the morning,
so about seven, eight guys, you know,
that I studied with and like my best
friends at the institution, you know,
we just hung out all night,
you know,
ate chips and talked and talked about
what I was going to do and I got out and
wow. You know, just the going away party.
That sounds like you were a love guy
in there, man. Oh yeah. Yeah. I got,
I had a lot of, a lot of
love in prison. You know,
it's crazy because even in prison,
uh,
when I played basketball or something
like that or football and people want to
file me hard, you know, the guys be
like, man, you can't do that to Rick.
You know? I mean, even right now,
you know this guys on the street that
they're wanting to hurt this dude. Wow.
They, they'd come up to me all
the time in la and like, man,
when I'm saying my most punch
him in the face, like snuck,
he got punched in the face. You're
going to snuck him. Yeah, I was with uh,
uh, went by Jim a couple of weeks ago
and this guy came up to me and he's like,
big Homie, when I seen, oh man,
it's on, on site. I was like,
Huh? I was like, Nah man. So I
just get a lot of love, you know,
because you know, the people
know my heart. They knew that
even though I did
something that was wrong,
it was out of ignorance and not
on purpose that I did what I did.
Well,
your story is very fascinating and for,
for the people that didn't hear
the first time you were to podcast,
you were a really good tennis
player and you essentially,
I bet you are you looking at,
you're in great shape,
but you essentially had no where to
go outside of high school because you
couldn't read, couldn't read or
couldn't go to college. You couldn't,
you stuck crazy.
I stuck
myself and, and you know
what? Me and Antonio, fine.
I'll just like 65% of the guys
in prison can't read. Wow.
So that would be one of the first
things to do to combat prison. Okay.
Let's make sure we teach all
of these guys how to read.
They don't teach you shit once
you get in there, right? No.
You had to force yourself. You have to
learn your stuff. I had to learn myself.
What I, you know, I had a
life sentence. So I had,
I had a great reason to I how
to read and my Lori was like,
well I'm not real motivated.
You don't have much money. Wow.
So I'm not really holding. Yeah. He told
me that. He really said that to you.
I'm not real motivated. You don't
have much money. And you know what?
He also told me
me something that that may be the best
thing that he ever did for me and my
whole life. And he told me
these words here. He said,
anytime somebody else wants
for you something more than
you want it for yourself,
then you're in trouble.
So what I took from that is that he was
telling me that if I was depending on
him to get me out of prison,
then I was in trouble.
So I took matters into my own hands.
Well,
only 1% of people ever get back a federal
license and for six years he had one.
That's amazing. It's an amazing,
it's an amazing story too.
It's amazing how the whole
thing transpired and the
fact that you didn't know
how to read when you first started on
your journey to try to figure out what was
wrong with your case. That's incredible.
Because I mean, you literally,
from the ground up how to do it,
I did it from the ground up.
That's why I know that,
that just about anybody can do it.
Yeah.
What was it like before you can read,
when you were 28 years old and you would
see like some shit written somewhere.
What did it look like? He has to read
a lot of things as a rich person.
Yeah. Right. Cool.
Where do you know, a lot of times I faked
it. If it was somebody around, uh, I fake,
you know,
that I could read,
write and I would look at it as if I had
read it and then we pass it on to them.
Like I said,
for contracts when I would go buy a house,
well I would look at the contract for a
little while and try to figure out in my
mind how long it would take a
person to read the contract.
And then I would hand it to whoever was
with me and tell them to read it and
then ask them, well what do
you think about this contract?
And then they would give me their
opinion. I think this. And I think that,
and then I would come up with my
own decision from, from there.
So when you were looking at the pieces
of paper, what were you thinking?
Just 1001 1002 I wish I could read.
I wish I could read when thousand
four I wish I could read. I should've.
That's
such a why.
Why can not learn how to read.
So what was wrong with me
when I was going to school?
Did anybody around, you know that
you didn't have to know how to read?
I don't know cause I hit it and,
and you know when you've got money,
what you find out.
Did you get a lot of people around you
that that is just right and tell you what
you want to hear and they don't question
right. And they can handle things for you
too. Yeah. So you just relied on that?
Yeah. What did it look like
when you looked at like,
if you looked at the cover of this rolling
stone and he saw all these letters?
I can't remember now
cause cause I can do it.
I don't know if I would have
looked at her owners don't really,
I don't know if I would've, you know,
I mean when you can't read, you know,
why are you going to be looking?
I don't think I ever tried to read
a magazine until I got to prison.
Did you like when,
when you see it,
do you remember that if
you recognize the letters?
Family had a magazine when
I was growing up. Oh Wow.
A magazine wasn't something
that was, I mean, who am I?
A house with a bottom magazine.
My mother wouldn't know my brothers,
you know? Uh, was there any
books? I don't think so.
What kind of books would
have been in our house?
My brothers was in the same position, you
know, my oldest brother can't read. Wow.
Even right now he has problem reading.
Uh, my younger brothers could we,
but I mean, what was they
going to read? You know,
they going to follow in my footsteps
in my older brother's footsteps.
So I don't think that we
had books in our house
and we got to remember, this is
like fresh off of Jim Crow, right?
It's five years right after Jim Crow.
I think even though we say Jim Crow
had ended in [inaudible] 65 66,
it probably didn't set in until,
you know, the late seventies. Right.
Yeah.
It's Kinda crazy when you wrap your head
around people saying that people need
to pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
I don't think a lot of people understand
how bad it is in some areas and they
can't even wrap their head around what
it is like to grow up when no one else
can read.
Yeah, it is. And or no one else tells
you that you should read, you know,
and in our neighborhood, the guys are
telling you you crazy for reading.
You're crazy for reading. Yeah.
Yeah. They're going to tell you, man,
get you a snatch bore,
you know, go get you a Ho.
A snatch bar.
That's what they call it.
Yeah. Snatch bores. Uh, a piece of
equipment that they used to steal cars.
Oh. Oh. Oh. Snatched initially. Not
with it. I thought that was a girl.
You're talking about snapchat or the
whole, which is here. He'll get you a hoe.
I was like, girl, did you know what he was
talking about? Yeah, that's fine. Prions,
totally gangster.
The hole was the girl, you know, cause
we stayed on Figeroa so, right. You Man,
get you a hole.
Put the book down.
You've being silly and you're gonna not
go make it. Get you a sec. Wow. Slang.
Get you a pistol and rob,
how many people around you
were when you were growing up?
We're not doing crime.
Well, I was growing up at,
yeah, I don't know. It was
just constant everywhere. Yeah.
Yeah. Crime was accepted in my
community. Crime was accepted.
That was one of the things that they were
really fascinated about me lasting so
long in the drug business is that
my neighbors allowed me to do it.
I mean,
my neighbors could have had me arrested
immediately because they knew what I was
doing. I've even had neighbors to
[inaudible] one time I stashed some,
some drugs inside a brick wall in
between my mom's house and my neighbor's
house, and it fell through
the fence into her yard.
And so she picks up, well, I
don't know, maybe like $200,000.
One for dope. Oh my God. Takes it in
her house. And then she tells my mom,
uh, tell Rick to come by here and see
me. And so when, when my, when I come,
my mom say, oh, Mary joy said, come
and see her. And then instantly I knew,
I knew what it was. Instantly. So I go
over there and I was like, you know,
got my head down, you know, all of stuff
because this lady is like my Auntie,
you know,
we grew up next to her and then she says,
I got your bag in the room
whenever you get ready for it,
just tell me to bring a tape.
Whoa.
So you know when I go get the bag and
then the next day I have guys to come over
and do like a $5,000 paint job on
her house, you know, and you know,
paint that house.
Nice. That's a smart
way to handle it, man.
That's the diplomatic way of
keeping the community happy.
Yeah. You got to [inaudible] and
that was a kind of good goodwill.
And I got in my,
in my neighborhood now she was anti
drugs because her daughter was,
was on drugs and was on drugs
before I started selling drugs.
Her daughter used to be on
PCP and ooze all strung out,
but she respected what I did and she
allowed me to conduct my business in her
neighborhood. What's, aren't
I rented respectfully to,
you know, it wasn't, no guns,
wasn't no gang bangers. Well, nobody
gonna get robbed over there. You know,
I made sure that you're not going
to come over here doing no Robin.
How did you keep it so civil? How, I mean,
how did you avoid the normal pitfall?
Well, I was willing to do
whatever it took. You know,
I was the police around here.
I police my neighborhood.
Wow. You know, you, you do
something around here, you know,
I'm a,
I'm gonna deal with you.
That's amazing.
Like how much of an area did you control?
Uh,
Los Angeles at one.
I mean,
you know,
it was a time man, when the, when
it started instead of the Christian,
blessed would get into it and they would
come and report to me. Man, you know,
those guys did such and such and
we're going to retaliate out. Hold Up,
let me go talk to him. Wow. So, you know,
and a lot of my guys said it that I really
put on the first peace treaty,
you know,
because for the first
time that we ever saw man,
it was crips and bloods selling
drugs on the same streets. Wow.
And I mean, you know, money money
will make you work together, you know,
money making,
how it brought the crips and the
bloods together. The, the, the, the,
the timing.
When Rodney King
happened, that's what brought
them together. Rodney King. Yeah.
But they w they had been working
together before that they had sold drugs
together. CRIPS and bloods had
sold drugs together in April.
Oh, I see. In Rodney King,
he recently pass away something drug drug
related wasn't any trout or something
like that. Got Too high. I don't know.
I don't remember what it was. Yeah.
That's what I had read this in
the system and a lot of stuff.
It's amazing that, uh, that,
that sorta opened up people's eyes
to what the fuck could happen.
You get pulled over by the
police like a lot of times people
stories. Yeah. Got It. I
got this experience it.
See all these cars in my faith. That's
flashlight therapy, baby shit. Yeah.
I didn't have the dog bite me up
while I was handcuffed. Oh God.
I got the boot marks in my back.
You know where they stump me and
I haven't been through it.
I was Rodney king like four or
five years before Rodney King.
Most people who have
never seen that before.
Rodney king had no idea that that could
go on unless you saw like the video from
the Chicago. Uh, was it the Democratic
convention in the 60s where they,
the cops beat the fuck out of those
kids. Yeah. There was, uh, some,
some convention in the 60s where the cops,
she has beat the fuck out
of these kids with clubs.
And it was horrific because it was on TV
and people got to see it for the first
time when the news,
it was before Kent State when they
shot those kids who were protesting the
Vietnam war. And it was, um,
it was one of the first times,
but then the Rodney king one
was like a recent one, you know,
it wasn't the news doing it.
It was one of the first ones
where people with a camera,
because the whole camera thing was like
a fairly new thing or a regular person
would have a video camera before you
would have to be a guy likes making movies
or some shit.
But it got to the point where the
technology got to the look of the common
person could have a video
camera and then boom,
they could catch someone doing something.
Got Guys in south central,
they got little cameras that they strapped
to their chest and walk around with
it. And uh, I forgot what they call them,
but uh, they have them on all the time.
All the time. That's the way they
keep the police. I'll call Brian.
Brian has glasses, I have glasses
and a pen. It looks like a big pen,
but it's like does the HD, oh yeah,
you can just set it down, you know,
and record HD and
yeah,
they have that spy shop would,
that's all they specialize in like shit
that you can like wear hats and stuff
that film and things along those lines.
Yeah. I was with, uh, with a,
with a guy the other night and he
had this thing and I was like, man,
what's that on your chest? He
said, well that's my police camera.
He said they can't cut it off either.
Cops got busted recently
slamming some girl on the ground,
picked her up and slammed her twice.
She got pulled over though. No.
Which he got pulled over for a, um, a
cell phone ticket. That's it. Wow. Yeah.
Oh my God. Oh, the cell phone thing. Oh my
God. This cell phone tickets or you know,
they, they're, they're
saying that like a, like $120
but everyone I know that has got
one. It's been like 800, $900.
Why is it that one? Quite a few. Yeah.
Like there's all these extra
bullshit charges to it. And
I guess that's why they slammed
into the ground. It was $800.
That's ridiculous. Hey, up the enforcer,
I think cops are used to doing that.
I think they've been doing that
since the beginning of time.
Have you heard of that one comp that
they found in Florida that might be a
serial killer with the wife? No.
Different guy. I know that guy too.
But another guy who pulled over
to a separate people said yeah.
Said he brought them to
the SARC. Okay. And uh,
dropped him out and then
there's no video at the circle.
K The security camera does
not show him or the guy there,
there's no evidence of him making
calls that he allegedly makes.
And he also runs like searches on these
people and says that he doesn't even
know who they are. Like I don't even
remember meeting anybody. Like, I dunno,
like you said it like three different
stories. I found the car abandoned that.
Like he's got all these different stories,
but meanwhile,
both guys are completely off the
face of the earth. They vanished.
And there's just people that he just
pulled over for speeding or for whatever,
or Morgan. Yeah. There's some guys like
his mom was like interviewing. She's like,
he would definitely call me if he was
alive. I was like, yes, I heard that.
That was what was exactly the Latino.
Yeah.
The Latino guy didn't even speak English.
They were both from Mexico and
him and his brother were set up.
Bray, the cop took his brother, so
he's going to drop him off at circle.
Tastes just kill this motherfucker.
Just probably, who knows? You know?
I think they, I think
human beings when they, we,
they get into a position of power,
they lose objectivity and they start
looking at it as an US versus them thing.
You know?
Especially, I don't know, Joe,
I think that's a pessimistic view a
little bit because I look at Rick and I
think that one of the aspirational parts
of him is that he got into power and he
shared it.
I mean everyone.
Sure. But I think for the most part,
that is how people behave. I mean,
that's how cops behave. It's not every
cop that behaves like that. Obviously.
I know a lot of good cops, especially
from a Jujitsu, from martial arts.
I'm always around cops and I know
a lot of them that are really cool.
But I know a lot of cops there
cons, you know, and it's just,
it just is what it is. And then I think
the ones like the serial killer guy,
you know, and the, the ones like the guy
who slams those people on the ground,
I mean those, those guys
exist, you know, it's a,
and they have absolute power.
Yeah.
But how about the fucking kid who was
handcuffed and shot himself in the back of
the head in the car and the police in
the back seat of a police car handcuffed.
They didn't find a gun on him,
but he had a gun.
So he pulls out the gun and
shoots himself in the head. Like,
like why? And I think it was for like a
DUI or something crazy. Right? It was,
it wasn't even like anything.
Not that serious. It wasn't
like he was going to go,
go to jail for the rest of his life.
Not that, you know, a DUI is a serious,
but I don't know if it's serious
enough to get you to kill yourself.
I should actually actually
say what the fuck that is.
I should actually Google that.
I saw cough,
I saw Louis C k last
night at the Improv and man, that guy
is rolling around like a rock star now.
He sold out two shows at the thing and
then went to the comedy store and sold
out the main room in 20,
like 20 minutes.
Yeah. And um, he had a midnight show
and I think he like sold the tickets,
cash only cash only. It's
hilarious. And, and wow man,
all new material. Uh, how was it?
I wasn't even allowed in the room.
That's how crazy packed it was.
I couldn't even look in the room
at the comedy store, which is, if,
you know the comments are your yeah,
you're a regular,
you usually can like sit in the
back or like look in the back.
Couldn't even do that was to pack.
That's amazing.
But everyone said it was amazing shows.
Yeah. He asked me for him to
go, but I was too tired. Um,
I'm trying to find out what this kid did.
Uh,
they're just this, this, I
don't want to keep looking,
but the whole thing is crazy like that
a person could handcuff, handcuff,
shoot themselves in the temple.
Joe Does. Part of that is the
danger of this, of this wraparound.
We did an article on Luke 21,
uh, called, uh, uh, Rick Ross,
a hip hop's war against black men.
When we really talk about the danger
I've putting out these perpetual criminal
black man images and,
uh,
we look more at Trayvon at that
time and just discuss the reality.
And this is an interview of me and Rick
and we discussed the reality of when you
put that image out, how it creates
fearmongering not only amongst the cops,
but also regular citizens like Zimmerman.
People just have that already in their
head when they, when they see the CDC, uh,
Trayvon with the IC walking home.
Absolutely insane.
Yeah. It's the, the
perpetual, um, criminal image.
It really in, in a, in like the
way it entered into white society.
It was a gangster rap and the 80s because
before that it's like there was never
any entertainers that would
brag about being criminals.
Like that shit didn't exist. No, it
never just sit and rock and roll.
There was a little bit of like a
shot a man in Reno just to watch him.
I mean that was about as crazy as it
got. You know, it never got like Nwa.
I mean I remember I was a kid and I was
listening to Nwa while I was on that I
was on a stair climber.
I was like,
this is the craziest Shit
I've ever listened to.
What the fuck they're saying like
this is nuts. Like they are just out.
And I was thinking, man, society's going
down the shitter. This is craziness.
And then you look at that cover and you,
you come back to the question that you
asked, why does he have to look like that?
Right.
Was that the whole photo shoot or was
that just the craziest shot that they
found in the photo shoot?
At least he doesn't have a gun on him.
And this is not like holding up diamond
crusted gun. Pulled up your pants
sagging thing man.
And just take a nice picture.
You take a nice picture for [inaudible]
to own mills fucking underwear photo
look in his underwear. It's so silly.
What that picture is is I don't care.
But they do have a picture of him
in his uniform and his book and his
correctional officer uniform.
I'll do that. Brilliant. Yeah, I'm
going get his award. You know he was the
best CEO at the, at the academy. The best.
What do you have to do to be
the best perfect attendance?
That's what you got to war for. Uh,
get a guy that got an extra stamp,
an extra scoop you up.
There's a picture of him.
I got his girlfriend too long on a visit
and you bust his ass and put him in the
hall. Is that what he does?
Or a rapping over there.
And then you break up the wrap
group and it's still all the lyrics.
So give me all those papers you think
he's told lyrics from people too. Oh,
absolutely. For sure. Yeah. He
doesn't write his own music.
Is there a lot of rappers in jail that
are talented guys that are stolen? Yeah.
Guys in jail got stories. You know
they, they, they, they, they been here.
Yeah,
and you see it live.
That is so ridiculous.
It's so strange.
The DECA, why didn't you put down
on the coast? Look at the cover.
It's two different people.
It's two different people that beer
does look like Ali gene, the dictator.
Brian, see if he can pull up
anything about his beard. I try.
I tried looking for it. Yeah, I
did. Shit looks fake. It's fake.
Even if it's not fake, who
cares? The whole thing is silly.
It's silly and ridiculous.
Listen man,
I hope the one thing that we got out of
this podcast is we started the Rick Ross
podcast.
That's what you need to do and by the way,
just call it the Rick Ross podcast and
this fool is going to get you millions of
listeners almost immediately,
and you could spell it out at
the beginning of every podcast.
Just nice and clean and simple.
If you're going to this podcast thinking
that it's Rick Ross, the wrapper,
you been misled. It says though,
Real Rick Ross that Rick Ross,
the wrapper ripped his name off from,
you know why?
Because I was one of the most successful
drug dealers in the history of the
United States and I went to jail and he
thought it was going to Jeff for life,
but I learned how to read in jail and
I got out because I found a hole in the
fucking case. And now here I am
on the Rick Ross podcast. Boom.
That's the beginning of every episode.
They would listen to that and then
every kid who had listened to it,
who was probably a Rick Ross
Fan, the fake guy, the rapper,
we'll listen to that first couple seconds,
just you saying if you thought this
was Rick Ross the rapper, nope.
This is the dude that Rick Ross stole his
fucking name from the real rich people
would be like,
what stole his name?
Then they get out their phones and
start googling shit. That alone
might take this dude down or
at least get them to pay. Yeah,
I mean we,
every time he comes out with something,
if you really search the Internet,
like that rolling stone article
came out on that Friday. Right.
And we did a release a
letter, uh, Rick, uh, Rick,
Rick and I sat down and I got his ideas
and we did a letter and for the whole
weekend when you searched
Rick Ross rolling stone,
you can search it right now.
Check it on Google.
If you
start to Rick Ross were on the stone,
like the top replies or our stuff and it
looked like it'd be just do Rick Ross,
you do your thing that comes
up news for Rick Ross as you,
you know, so like people are like that
are searching for him automatically.
See the number one news thing
is it is a interview with you.
So I'm Rick Ross Rolling Stone.
Okay. All right. I'll Google.
The whole thing is crazy.
And the whole America is crazy though.
America is crazy. It's definitely
bizarre. You got a phone call and make
Oh, okay. The fake beard
thing. That's funny. He's,
he's determined to let the world
know about this fake beard thing.
Trademark trademark beard as well.
The name's not enough.
You've got to him and got a fake beard.
If you find out that Baird is fake,
that is so key. You fend to see.
I haven't just that
statement you fin to see.
Oh Man, I can't wait. I can't wait to
see it. God, I hope it's really good.
Do you find it Brian?
You know what to search for now?
Oh Gosh. Like beard. Come on son.
That's ridiculous. That's going to
be the wrap, right? It's ridiculous.
The Internet levels,
the whole playing field in terms of like,
even if if mass media doesn't want to
cover certain things with the Internet
allows us to do is is immediately
put pressure through. Oh Wow.
When did you notice the
most? The most. That's fine.
Is that him? That's not him. That's
how you do it. I guess how you,
that's how the style of how you do it, how
you fill it in. Oh, we'll go to him, man.
That's fine. Him. This
is just a dude getting,
I think this is what
they're talking about.
Know what they're saying is how you fill
it in and do it if it isn't coming in
all together. Oh, okay.
Once you go to it. Yeah.
We got to see him do it though.
I don't think they have him.
Oh, there's no, there's no actual
Rick Ross footage of him getting this.
No, no, no. Okay. Damn.
We're just speculating.
That's not good enough.
Yeah.
We got to find out the actual facts.
We can't just talk shit on the dude.
This is enough shit to talk
shit on anyway. I mean, how is,
how is this guy sad?
This they're putting paste
on his face like that.
That spirit gum that you use for like
fake mustaches and it looks like,
which is like a really sticky oh man. Use
it on their head. Yeah. Glue and then,
then it looks like they're not there.
They're gluing hair on this false face.
Oh Wow. This is not just it like
the, the, the spray on, Oh shit.
This is like fake actual
hairs are in there. Oh,
this is crazy. Oh, that's disgusting.
That's exactly how it looks.
That's exactly how he does it though. I
mean it's, but look how stupid that looks.
Who would want a beard? It
looks like that a superhero. All
right.
Yeah. That's like a wax
figure. It looks so weird.
So weird. I got booger.
That is a very strong,
you get a perfect a perfect beer.
That's a strange thing to do.
What your fucking time. I don't
even want my perfect no more. Yeah,
you're better off.
That looks like look like madness.
That looks like a crazy person.
Like he's determined to get that
shit perfectly smooth. Creepy.
What is the best thing
that's come out of this man?
Well, I'm out of my whole life.
The best thing that's come out now is
that I'm able to go back and tell kids the
real story.
You know how a person can go
from being a tennis player,
uh, to selling drugs. You know,
almost overnight. You know,
one day I was a tennis player and
the next day I'm a drug dealer.
Um,
so it's not like they tell you that this
big mean monster's going to come down
and you start you to selling drugs.
One of my best friends
called me selling drugs.
He showed me cocaine from our first time.
He explained, he explained it to me.
Uh,
he sold me on the idea.
And what I think is so important
that these kids, you know,
that that's how you're going
to get introduced to drugs,
not by some stranger, uh,
not from Rick Ross.
The drug dealers not going to come down
and introduce you to drugs, you know,
it's going to be somebody close to you.
So I think with me using my
experience and my story to,
to educate the world, you
know, I believe that, that,
that we definitely need educating. And,
um, that's what I'm doing now. You know,
we're doing a documentary called crack
in the system. Uh, we still underfunded.
Don't know what Mark Levin,
Mark Levin has done.
HBL director who just did a prayer for
a perfect season and uh, last on long,
I didn't, hard times. It's nominated
for some Emmys. We expect to be,
we expect to get some Oscar nods on
this documentary. It's that powerful.
There's so many different
facets and phases of your life.
It's so interesting to
have your, you know, uh,
run in Los Angeles phase to
being incarcerated with no
hope of escaping phase to
figuring out how to read phase
to now educating kids phase.
This is a, I mean, what is the,
what is it like to be at
this phase of your life now?
Like reflecting back on all the
madness of the previous phases.
It's like, wow, you know, uh,
this is what you had to go through to
become who you are today. You know,
had I not went through
all those scenarios,
had I not been bitten by the dog,
beaten in the head with flashlights,
had drugs planning on you by the police,
could I be able to rationalize all of
the things that I ration with right now?
You know,
being able to sit in prison with a
guy that you gave his first drug too,
and he has a life sentence.
And at one time we both got lights,
him life sentences.
You know,
this guy wanted to be like me
so that he not only copied me,
but he also went to prison with me,
had a life sentence with me.
We walked the track and then I have to
walk when I walked out of prison to leave
him there.
Uh,
all these things shaped
me for who I am today.
And I believe that that's what gives
me the ability to be able to walk in a
board room with an Ori Manual
or Jeff Bird or Michael Lynton.
And then I can leave from there and go
to south central watts and go to Jordan
high school and sit there
and talk to the kids.
How many dudes get out after long
stretches like that and they become
institutionalized and they
can't take the regular world.
I think it's, it's, it's, it's
a lot. I mean, even myself,
I was institutionalized when
I was in prison. I mean,
because I function in prison,
uh, at a high level, you know,
prison didn't affect me,
you know, like right now,
even when I got into it with my po and
he was talking about sending me back,
I was like, send me back for a year a
year. It's nothing I can do a year on,
on a handstand,
you know?
So I believe that it's very
easy to get institutionalized.
It's very easy to start to go with
the flow. Started to like being there,
uh, to, to, to say that the world on
the outside is not real. You know,
that being in here is what's
real. I mean, I had a friend,
I just heard a couple of weeks ago,
he did 20 years flat with me.
We started out at the same time.
Matter of fact,
he started out a little before I did.
And uh,
before that he did juvenile hall and
had been incarcerated orders night with
just the other week. He went and did
one of the stupidest crimes that,
that that you,
you can't believe it.
He almost had a life
sentence for crack cocaine.
He went and sold somebody two ounces
of crack cocaine out here. Uh,
and now he's back in jail and he's looking
at a life sentence all over again or
20 years. God Damn the, the guy,
that guy is intelligent.
It's kind graduated from college.
So while he was in prison, he went
to college. He got degrees. I mean,
just a brilliant guy.
But did he move right back home
to his own old stomping ground?
He had nowhere else to go. What was
he going to go? I mean, you know,
when you get out of jail, you do 20
years, you, you don't have anything.
You don't have many
body. I mean, you know,
he was lucky that his father
took him in and you know,
he just slid back in, you know,
to, to, to what he knew. You know,
I think drugs becomes like a
crutch for the seller. You know,
where if something goes wrong,
he knows how to fix it and that
should go out and sell him some drugs.
And you know, now I've got a place to
live. I got gas in my car, I'm eating. Uh,
I'm respectful again.
You know?
Did any of that could ever be
stopped? Is there a map? I mean,
you must've spent a lot of time thinking
about the whole system of illegal drug
trade and you know, what got you into
this? Is there a way to ever stop that?
Well, we're going to have to give real
opportunity, not fake opportunity.
Uh,
like so many people are selling right now.
You know,
so many people right now are selling us
fake opportunity when there's really no
opportunities. There's no
manufacturing jobs. You know,
they sent all our jobs overseas. I
mean, if you want to be a operator,
you got to go to India, you know? Uh,
so what we're going to have to do is
figure out how we can make our people feel
important. Again. How, how do
you make up a person feeling
Ken that stopped drugs though
cannot stop the sale of drugs.
And if drugs are illegal,
are they always going to be wanted?
Is it always going to be a market
for them that's a criminal market?
Absolutely.
I believe that the only way we can solve
this drug problem is with education.
Because like you said,
as long as there's a demand for drugs,
there's going to be a supplier.
Once we end the demand,
then
the suppliers are automatically go away
because they're not going to be standing
around holding drugs that nobody wants.
Right. So we gotta educate people.
That's a high level of education.
The point where they don't want drugs
cause even this motherfucker loves drugs.
He's always good.
There's one thing inside
of what Rick is saying,
it's very powerful and we got to
realize that when the seller is selling,
his drug isn't only the money,
it's the power and the respect.
And if you can find an alternate way for
that person that I'm not saying get the
same level of respect but be respected,
then you can give them an alternate
route that isn't as dangerous.
They might choose that over
the extra money. Oh for sure.
Well everybody would more certainly
choose a Karma free form of success over
success. It involves like real dangerous
shit and going to jail, getting shot.
It's just a, how do we get people to
aspire that high? I mean we gotta,
we gotta do a lot of work on the
culture of this country, of the,
just the way we, just, the
way we raise human beings.
I mean all of this from sneaky to this
ridiculous nonsense that we feed each
other. It's like, oh,
it's okay if it's just you at the
airport picking it up and laughing.
But it's the people that actually get
influenced by that influenced by this Ding
Dong culture of nonsense
and fake drug sales and,
and fake shooting people. It's
like what, what are we promoting?
Like what the fuck are we doing?
Is it just a, a mad money grab
responsibility? Exactly. I mean
they don't have any responsibility.
I think that if you allow a magazine,
they put a guy in here who sent in.
I sell drugs.
Okay.
They should be held accountable for that.
I mean,
cause all I did and selling drugs. Let
me tell you what I did in selling drugs.
Really. Cause I, you know, I didn't
manufacture the drugs. Right?
All I did was got the drugs from
one guy and hand him to another guy.
Okay.
So if you handing off drug information,
you should,
you should be liable for
that type of inflammation.
If you putting out records
where you telling kids to go
out and sell drugs to parlay that
into a record. It's funny, outlandish,
but like when we look at Nwa,
you talked about him earlier.
The FBI went after Nwa when cops
started getting shot up after,
after Nwa came out with the cocktail
and saw the FBI had made an attempt to
charge Nwa.
Wasn't that ice tea?
Actually it wasn't that they
have one to fuck the police,
but the FBI went after them under the
concept that they're perpetuating the
image they're putting out that's making
people do this and the same thing goes.
That's what it should go.
It should go,
it should go. But they're making
money off the drug trade in a,
in a sort of a peripheral entertainment
based way. Right. That's what it is. Yeah.
So they really are making money off
the glamorization of the drug trade.
But you, you, you, you forget
the other part of it, which is,
I mean sometimes you see,
I don't know if you've ever seen where
they'll rip down a building just to
create the jobs that built the
building back up with them.
Making money off of now is actually
ripping down black men's lives.
And some of these cases,
cause like what's happening is these black
men come out in these areas and I'm a
former prosecutor here in la and he's
black men are born into certain areas
where their crime or their drug,
they're drug infested.
And then essentially they go
out and they sell the drugs.
And instead of fixing the drug problem
by saying we not gonna let the drugs in
the community know more, what they
do is then pushed him into prison.
But you got to remember it's not
just pushing them into prison.
There's jobs all along the way, which is
like somebody got a typing, uh, his name.
Somebody got to file his,
his paperwork.
These are jobs for everybody else other
than the black people. They get to, uh,
basically manage this, this
destruction of these, this man's life.
Yeah.
There is unquestionably a whole industry
involved and keeping people locked up.
There's an industry involved
and going after people,
there's an industry involved and even
making sure that people continue to commit
crimes, making sure that things, and
he shouldn't even be crime stay crimes.
So keep people in jail.
And that's hard for people to accept,
especially those no nonsense.
Mitt Romney love and dudes,
that's not the way things work.
You're crazy conspiracy theorist,
but know that that really is,
they're going to pay $40,000
to keep you in prison,
but we are not going to get you a job
where you can make 18,000 a year and then
you won't commit a crime.
It's crazy how many people are in jail.
And I don't think most people understand
that the numbers in America are higher
than anywhere else in the world.
I go, this is the crazy part is, uh,
the numbers in America right now
and about 700 per hundred thousand,
like the highest, the highest that
you've seen basically in the world,
but the highest rate ever in recorded
nation is about 800, 400,000.
That was in Russia during the, during
the war camps. Uh, the high, the,
during the African apartheid for
the Africans that were oppressed,
it was like eight 52 per 100,000 for
black men today, between 25 and 35,
it's 10,000 per hundred
thousand that are in prison.
Holy kinds. The highest rate. Yeah. Great.
Ever. And, and the thing is,
it's not even part of the DNC
convention at all. No, no, no.
Of It as a platform. So you have all
these, when you watched the convention,
and funny enough, this
is no degrade, but it's,
it's a lot of African American women.
Well,
if your father or your brother
or your uncle was in prison,
you should demand that that's
part of their platform.
How is that not part of a platform
like that that they address?
Why are these men have went to prison
for nonviolent offenses for as long as
they have?
Yeah. When the numbers are that high,
it seems like that's a social academic.
Yeah, it's an epidemic. They have to,
they have to figure out what caused that,
that situation and treat it
like an outbreak of a disease.
Like there's something fucking terribly
wrong in this one area is one area.
What was the number again? 10,000
pro. It's 10,000 per hundred thousand
for black men between 25 and 35 overall
it's 5,000 per 100,000 so that tells you
the old ones aren't as, I don't go
into prison as much as the youngs.
It's a, it's a scary number.
That's a terrifying number.
Cause 10,000 for 100,000 would.
That's ten one 10 that's
insane. Yeah. One in 10 in jail.
That's not even counting. The ones
that are, that broke a cycle. Got,
doesn't even make sense.
That seems like it's impossible
because you think about it.
How many people are actually in the hoods?
Not all black guys are in the hood,
so a lot of black guys are glowing.
Growing up in suburban neighborhoods,
you have to factor in.
The hood must be way higher than one
in 10 it's probably 50% it's probably
something nutty.
Like
they'll talk about unemployment
or something like that.
You know when they talk
about these numbers,
like 15% or I think like
it's 50% that's not right.
Well,
you know what?
The numbers are there only in people
haven't been looking the when the,
when people stop looking at the
numbers don't show up at my brothers.
They're not looking for a job. They
didn't even count on unemployment. I mean,
I don't, I don't understand unemployment
rates. I don't, I don't know.
I don't understand how a president can
create jobs either. When they talk,
we created 100,000 jobs.
Like what did you,
what did you do to create jobs
and yeah, maybe that's it, right?
Yeah. No Shit, man. It's a strange world.
We have to figure out a way to make it
profitable for evil companies to make
people smarter and clean up crime.
If we could figure out a way to take
Halliburton out of Iraq and have them
rebuild south central,
make it a trillion dollar contract
to rebuild fucked up areas.
Wouldn't that be an amazing
way to use resources? I mean,
I'm in south central though. There's not,
yeah, the one, if you really believe that,
that's why we're in that
camp or Iraq. Yeah. You, um,
but you've got to think that there has
got to be some benefit in the resource of
human beings and developing,
developing intelligent human beings.
This is a country that slavery, by
the way, every country had slavery,
every single country. Not only
that, most of them still do.
I wonder how many countries still rocks.
I mean, including America. I mean,
when not when I'm playing games,
if we pretend that we don't have slavery
here because all people that are here
without green cards or worker
cash essentially are slaves.
All those poor folks who can't get,
they can't get a green card. You know,
you sneak over here from
Mexico, man, good luck.
You sneak over here from anywhere else.
A good, good luck. You got to exist.
You know, day to day, hoping
you don't get found out,
you're never going to make more than a
certain amount of money unless you do
something illegal. You know? I mean,
and how many people are slavery and
other countries where they take people's
passports away and they make
them work on construction sites.
There's a lot of slavery is still going
on and apparently he's busting people
here and there for a basement full of
indentured servants. You know, it's, it's,
it's like slavery officially went away,
but it's still,
there's parts of the world were slavery.
It's pretty goddamn commonplace.
That's amazing. And 2012 were
that fucked up, you know,
you'd imagine it. That was
something we could have got rid of.
What's amazing when you think or how
recent slavery in the United States was?
Yes, it is. A couple of
hundred years, ain't shit.
It's not even a couple hundred years.
There was a PBS special, right?
There was a PBS special called slavery
by another name. I had Rick watch it.
The guy that, that, that
did the documentary work
for the Wall Street Journal.
And what he showed is
that why we ended up,
we ended slavery with the emancipation
proclamation at 1860s we didn't really
insulate be till 1945 that's when the FBI,
when you said,
my brother is being held
as a slave on his farm,
that's the first time the FBI went
and investigated it. So for anything,
they just let it go. Just let it go. And
then this is the kicker. They, I didn't,
I mean,
he showed that between 1865 and 19
like 60 only one white person was ever
convicted of a murder
of a black man one time.
Wow. These are, these are the
Democratic national convention. Again,
didn't talk about any of that. Whoa.
They didn't see the documentary. Oh yeah.
See, I, you know,
there's,
there's people that will get angry when
someone talks about reparations for
slavery.
But if you don't think that the culture
needs to put a certain amount of
emphasis on something that happened
in the previous century that you know,
I mean if that's really
1940 the previous century,
that might control the fate of millions
and millions and millions of Americans
that are in fucked up situations. It just
seems like to me, I've always said this,
I'll say it one more time. The the society
stronger when you have less losers.
It would seem to me that if you
really wanted to make America better,
you don't go to foreign countries.
He take all the,
the kids that are growing up fucked up
and you figure out a way to get them.
Counselors,
you figure out a way to bring in sports.
You figured out a way to get an education.
You figure out a way to,
it seems to be way cheaper to do that
than it would be to go to Afghanistan with
tanks.
You don't see it. You would send this
cocaine worst. They correct. What's that?
I said you would send his cocaine.
Where's the crack too?
That seems like a logical as
well that that whole thing.
It's silly isn't it? Crack is worse than
cocaine. If for as far as sentencing,
right,
it's a hundred times worse.
They moved to to 18 it didn't do
it retroactive hundred times worse.
It was since a hundred times worse.
So solid to put it in context so people
can understand you for five little rocks.
You got sentences the same amount
as if you had half a kilo. Whoa.
That's [inaudible] and it's not just
about the size of it is the realization
that only a few people will get
to the half a kilo level of sales.
Everybody does this five rock sales level,
so it was just a poor crackheads
off the street at will.
They could just lock everybody in jail
as long as they want it to. And when was,
when we're private prisons
introduced into this society,
probably around 80 89 something like that.
You should find out how and we
should know. That seems like a,
that seems like a fucking
huge Reagan era mistake.
You know when we're
private prisons invented,
but I know they definitely
corrupted the system.
When you let big corporations
get into prisoners, you know,
you know that number, like I
gave you earlier, black male,
black imprisonment in the 70s was like 10%
92 first happened in the United Kingdom.
Okay.
In 1992 they figured it out.
These motherfuckers
as a lot of jobs to the economy
though. Yeah. Crazy. Yeah,
I guess it does, right? Yeah. You got
to have somebody, the process file,
the paperwork you got
have correctional officers
feed them. Yeah. Like William,
somebody's got to feed them, you know,
grow the food even though they grow
the food they sell, but they won't. Uh,
they won't feed that
food to the prisoners.
Actually in the United
States, in, in, in England,
they started in the 90s
by the United States.
They've been doing it since the 18
hundreds beginning in 1868 convict leases
were issued to private parties
to supplement their workforce.
And then that's part of this documentary,
a slavery by another name as well.
What they showed is that is that chase
JP Morgan after slavery ended in 1865
what they did effectively is they would
make it a crime for you not to have a
job. It's called vagrancy laws.
And then once they captured you,
they would give you like three days,
but once you couldn't pay that,
your fees made it so like it was just
longer and longer and then they would
throw you in the mind to work it
off and you have a dye in the mind.
That's essentially what
they're saying here.
They're saying that farmers
and businessman needed to
find replacements for the
labor force once their
slaves had been freed. Yeah.
So beginning in 1868 convict leases were
issued to private parties to supplement
their workforce. That's fucking
crazy. They just found a loophole.
They made people go right back to
slavery by just locking them up in jail.
So jail really essentially private
prisons are a an off shoot of sleep.
Yeah.
Yes. It really is an extension of
something called the pig law. That was a,
and it's funny because the number is more
important than the name of the law of
the pig law. The minimum sittings. If you
stole, if you were a black guy, you still,
the white guys pick you. You were
given five years and a felony status.
Well the mandatory minimum for crack, it's
five years in a felony status. Wow. So,
so,
so they're not,
you know,
to genius would they want,
so what happens was in what they did
was they did this in an 1860s after the,
um, after slavery was
instituted, it was made illegal.
But then in the 1980s,
that's when shit kicked
in to the next level.
And that was the crack epidemic.
The crack epidemic actually
opened up the door to, uh,
ushering a new era of private,
uh, private prisons. Absolutely.
It's amazing, man. They just,
they realize they can make money.
Yeah, absolutely. And then, and
then if you look at this music,
this music doesn't help because it
perpetuates and it almost like a,
it's like Viagara was six.
You say you listen to this music,
you become a little
violent, angry, low person.
And then you do something
that you normally might not
do if you listen to Marvin
Gaye.
It's true.
That's a good point. You won't
hurt. Nobody lives in Marvin Gaye,
modern private prison business first
emerge and established itself publicly in
1984 when the corrections corporation
of America was awarded a contract,
it take over a facility in
Hamilton County, Tennessee.
How much would it suck to go to jail
and Hamilton County, Tennessee? Hmm.
When these motherfuckers passed that law.
Yeah.
They will put you in this line and then
you wouldn't even see the light of day.
And they would, and the thing about
being a prisoner versus a, a slave,
they said is that at least as a slave,
you are property.
So they have some value
for you as property,
but when you're a prisoner they just
throw you away. So then they didn't,
they treat you worse.
Unbelievable. They would just call it
the jail. Didn't tell him how he died.
Yeah.
Prison is worse than slavery.
We need to know that there's a benefit
for you being able to work to be healthy.
So there's a benefit of them
feeding you and keeping you alive.
Private companies in United States
operate 264 correctional facilities.
Holy Shit.
Private prisons,
there's 264 of them in this country.
They House almost 99,000 adult convicts.
This isn't sane, man. That's
crazy. That's a scary, scary,
scary statistic.
It just makes you really wonder who's
paying attention to any of this while
everybody's going over gay marriage.
What about gay marriage?
Like you need to pay attention to the
craziness at the base of our society.
Well, look what they did with the
crack law. No, they said, okay,
the crack law was wrong.
We're going to make an 18 and one but
there's guys had been in prison 25 30
years. Right now I'm selling
crack and there's no retroactive.
They didn't make it.
If they have made an 18 to one for them,
they get out tomorrow.
Ah Man. And the life was
just wasted. They do it.
They don't want to take a chance and
they can make money off you being inside.
And then the crazy part about the cracks,
sins in law is,
and I asked the another da this
that had more experienced it myself.
Is there any law on the books nonviolent
this punished that way? And he said, no.
I mean, yeah and it's a racist law. We
met the guy, we met the guy who wrote it.
He said that there's no law before or
when he's in our documentary cracking the
system. You guys got to check
it out when it comes out, uh,
let us know when is it going to be out
next year? Well, when it comes out,
come here,
come here again,
mother fucker through the roof.
You have him and Rick sitting on
the couch and he looks at ric dead.
I didn't sit and apologizes
to black America. He says,
I put more black men in
prison than anybody alive.
He said that I've never seen a law before
or after it that was written that way
without he, they didn't do
no investigation. The Da,
they didn't talk to the agents.
They didn't talk to lab specialists.
They just wrote the,
so they just wanted to figure out a way
where they can get people in jail that
aren't even going to complain.
And they did it during the era when there
must've been some pressure to clean up
the streets because I was,
the crack epidemic was crazy.
I remember the epidemic
people who, who now our guest, it
was crying out to to, you know, uh,
to change it. Yeah, man, it's fucking
nuts. But yeah, definitely. Uh,
uh, as soon as we, we get,
we still raising some money,
we got to raise a few more hundred
grand for this crack in the systems.
But what we did is we've been going
around investigating, doing all our work,
you know, going over archive footage
around the Reagan, talking about,
we've got Ronald Reagan talking
about crack cocaine, right.
We got,
we got a cop that was in that did five
years for basically it's planting drugs.
And for the first time
ever he's on camera.
He looks like fucking Deniro or somebody
classic. And so we got, we got him,
uh,
basically talking about what drove him
to plant drugs and to actually take
money, cause you know, you come in,
we're talking about 1980 you come into
a house with a 15 year old kid in there
and there's $60,000 on the, on the floor,
which is like $300,000 today. You're,
you know,
there's a lot of things that go through
your mind and when he goes through the
process of how you get to the point
where you take 150 and you reported 150,
right. And how his family needed things
and it's just crazy. This doc is go,
we going,
we going to ask it with this one.
Wow. I can't wait to see it. Definitely
come in right before it happens, man.
Come in right before you release it.
We'll, we'll blow that fucking thing up.
And um, one of the questions, what's the
most realistic movie on the drug trade?
Is there any realistic
movies that I saw like blow,
was that really close? Close. Close.
Yeah. That's why I let nick, right my, uh,
my script because I was the same guy.
It's writing your scripts. Yeah. Yeah.
Blow was really closed. What's
his name? Nick. What? Yeah,
he's supposed to direct a movie for us.
When is that going to happen?
We working on that right now too
is too short gun play. You know
Tim Shorrock
you're facially,
you guys look similar. A little bit too
short. They had a conversation last night.
No, I'm just a too short fan.
Is that right? Yeah. Great
Rapper. I let him know. Yeah,
please do man. I love that guy. He's in
town. I'm bringing him through. Please do.
Please do what? Uh, what
actor is going to play you?
We don't know yet. Uh, we tinkering
with what kind of quite a few people.
I talked to Jamie Foxx about a week ago.
Jamie Foxx can do anything.
Yeah. That guy can become anybody.
When then when I saw the Ray Charles,
I was like, nobody else could
have done that. And then,
then when they said he was going to play
Mike Tyson, I was like, he could do it.
They could do it. He could do it with a
picture with him, him and Jamie on it.
He could, uh, he could play Mike
Tyson and everybody's like, what?
He doesn't look anything like my,
so he could get to look like Mike Tyson
and he could pull it. He could do it.
I know he could do it.
Jamie had to be at and everything cause
he was doing just Django unchained.
Oh that's right. When is
that coming out? In December.
I saw the ads for it a while ago.
I supposed to come out the same heat.
When they do that,
they get your dick hard like six months
in advance for a good movie and then you
wait,
we gonna we gonna we gonna
knock 'em out with this.
When he talked to the real Scarface.
Wow.
I mean this is your real life story and
that's what really trips me out about,
about Hollywood is, you know,
when you come with a real story,
they don't really get that same type of
drive where they then yesterday somebody
come to me,
right?
They want to hire me as a consultant
to go on a TV show about a gangster in
south central Los Angeles. I'm like, well,
why are you guys doing a fictional story
when you got the real thing right here?
Oh, well it's probably too scary
for them right there. Yeah.
Yeah,
he could.
Yeah.
And what's crazy is we were talking to
a guy that did Benjamin buttons or how
you would make them look 20 again.
It's given us all the special effects.
Oh yeah, you could do amazing shit. And
see that movie tron where they took a,
what's up? What's on boys
now? The fucking older dude,
I want to say William hurt, but that's
on him now. Jeff Bridges. Jeff Bridges.
They turned Jeff Bridges back to where
he was when he was like 20 years old.
Benjamin buttons. They did that with the
Brad Pitt. Yeah, they could do anything.
It's as far as that. But as far
as like pulling it off, Jamie,
you got to get Jamie Foxx.
He played that homeless dude
who was the the music virtual,
so like he could do anything, man.
He's just one of those dudes. He just,
he didn't matter what he seems like when
he's just talking and interviews and
fucking around.
When it comes down to actual acting,
he's one of those dudes that
can become a different guy.
There's only a few of those.
Russell Crowe,
you know Daniel Day Lewis
type dudes out there.
But Jamie Foxx can do
the shit out of that.
That Ray Charles Man God
damn it was phenomenal.
And then when you realize he's
actually singing that shit.
That's what's even crazier. Like Jamie
Foxx is fucking incredible singer too.
Yeah. And the thing about our
script, the way it's written,
it's like a mix between traffic.
I would say traffic,
a blow and like Boyz in the hood. No
north face. No Scarface. Scarface too.
Well that's what I'm going
to tell you the interesting,
let me say one more thing about Scarface
cause we met with the producer of
Scarface and it's interesting cause
we were sitting in watching Scarface.
Remember that 83 is like
around the same time it's Rick.
And like when Scarface goes over
overseas to the, to the connection,
he's talking about like
a hundred keys a month.
Rick has done that a day. It's so
like, it's like, get your weight up,
Scarface,
just clown this story.
This story actually has a international
appeal. Just like I said, like Costa Rica,
tiny, he's picked up this
spin article. Oh, it's fast.
So we have the way it's written, it's
not just Rick, it's like 60%, 50% black,
30% Latino. And then, uh, the
other, the remainder is white.
So you have the reporter and you
have, uh, the, the politicians,
you have the Latino or the Nicaraguans
and then you have Rick story.
So this is just how the phenomenal,
uh, reach for everybody who, uh,
who likes different aspects
of those kinds of movies.
Yeah, that sounds pretty
fucking incredible, man. And
you know, so you, you haven't,
they don't have the, the, the, the
script's done, but they don't have a cast.
They don't have a d projection
when it's going to start via.
We still raising the budget right now.
You could sell crack cocaine
to make a lot of money.
[inaudible] you learn from the story.
The story is so important.
Now do you have a Kickstarter account?
Because that's, it seems like one of
the best ways to raise a bunch of money,
especially for a movie or something
like that through Kickstarter.
And if you ever have something like that,
please come back and we'll promote the
shit out of anything you guys want.
Anytime you want,
just let me know and you can come back.
We enjoyed the shit out of
this as well as the last time.
You know a cool motherfucker and your
story's amazing and thank you dude.
Thank you very much for all the
information that you distributed today.
And I think you guys have a great message.
You know,
I think both of you guys
are doing amazing shit.
Appreciate you having a song man. And
hopefully I continue to grow friends from,
from being on your show. You know? Oh,
you will go places and people call that
I saw you on Joe Rogan freeway, Ricky.
Unquestionably, man, listen,
we will help you blow up just like we
help everybody else, man. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Appreciate all y'all
out there who support me. I love you.
Yeah, we got some cool people that are
tuned in and I want to thank one of them.
Most Guy William Blankenship,
he apparently got upset because we use
some of his artwork and a caricature and
a and the recent ad for a Santa Barbara.
But you'd probably just pulled some shit
off lines. Yeah. Google search her name.
It's not labeled on our stand. How silly
it is, but it's like an Avatar. He,
we didn't know he wanted
to just get credit, so I'm
giving them credit. William,
thanks a lot dude. Thanks for making
that. No, he's not. He's not complaining.
He's just being a little needy.
You've got a freeway, Rick.
Tom Add is Facebook is Twitter. It's
all there. Or freeway. rick.com.
Real easy spell.
Yeah, go to death squad. Dot TV and pick
up to how many, how many cats are left.
Limited edition selling the second tee
shirt. Uh, it's half sold out right now.
In their bitches. The shits
everywhere. It's on MTV. All right.
Fake Rick Ross. Go Fuck Yourself.
You're ridiculous human being.
How dare you. Americans should say that
to you. How dare you. Well look, step two,
you will accept you. You're hustling
songs. A good song. Changing name,
sign and pay up, right. Lindy,
William, Bob, all that good shit.
All right folks,
thanks to ana.com for sponsoring
our podcast and Ting as well.
And um, uh, I forgot the
fucking Tang. God. Dammit.
God is saying in use. Uh, don't
make shit up. This is important.
Remember it's $50 then.
Yeah, you save 50 bucks.
I have a hard time using
this window. Shit, man,
I might not be able to make it with
this. Alienware okay, here's the, uh,
the actual address.
It's a rogan.ting.com and if you use that,
you'll save 50 bucks off of a,
a new fat android phone.
The galaxy s three is the one I got. Like
I said, it's delicious. Love it. And now,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com um,
uh,
go get yourself some kettle bells
and battle ropes and Alpha brain.
And all that good shit.
Use the code name Brogan,
and you will save 10% off any and all
supplements. All right, you dirty bitches.
We will see you next week. We got
a cat Monday's coming in. Um, uh,
I believe Eddie Bravo is
going to come in with her too,
because a Kat von d tattoo, Eddie
Bravo, his grandmom on his chest.
It's pretty fucking bad ass, right?
That's it. All right. Freaks. We love you.
We'll see you soon.
Yeah.